[Musique]
Jérémy Ferrari, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Euh ben je m'appelle Jérémy Ferrari.
Je suis humoriste
et je suis en direct sur Skyview.
Sur
Skyview, c'est ça ? Seriew. Ah, c'est
pas Je croyais que c'était plus mégalo.
Je pensais que tu avais mis ton nom
dedans.
Non, non, non, on est une team, on peut
pas être mégalo. On laisse les de côté
ici. Euh, vous avez fait un un spectacle
qui n'est pas récent mais qui qui est
sorti il y a combien de temps ? Ça
s'appelle vente vente d'un de pièces à
beou, comment ça s'appelle ?
Vente de pièces à beouth. Euh vente de
pièces à beou, on l'a lancé il y a il y
a 3 ans à peu près. Euh donc oui, c'est
plus récent maintenant. D'ailleurs, on a
terminé le la tournée. On a on a terminé
la tournée en France. le 14 février
dernier et puis après on a continué, on
a refait quelques dates aux États-Unis,
au Canada et puis là j'ai fait la
dernière à Montréal il y a quelques
semaines et maintenant c'est terminé.
Vous avez bossé 2 ans la géopolitique ?
Ouais. Alors
le niveau niveau avec lequel j'ai
démarré, on peut pas vraiment dire que
j'ai bossé 2 ans de la géopolitique
parce que le départ le tout démarrage du
travail c'était déjà reprendre vraiment
les bases de géographie d'histoire parce
que comme je suis pas vraiment allé à
l'école, il a fallu que que je reprenne
je crois qu'on a redémarré au niveau 6e
donc il y a eu d'abord une remise à
niveau. C'està dire, j'ai travaillé la
géopolitique, on a l'impression que j'ai
commencé sur des trucs hyper compliqués,
mais j'ai d'abord juste repris un peu
les bases en fait de de du truc et puis
au fur et à mesure, on a on est allé
vers des choses un peu plus un peu plus
complexes. Après,
je voulais pas le but c'était pas de
devenir un expert en géopolitique,
c'était vraiment de
comment on va dire de comprendre les
grandes lignes de ce qui pouvait se
passer un peu partout dans le monde.
C'était ça le but.
Donc ça consistait en quoi ? Vous avez
lu des bouquins, vous avez pris des
cours, vous avez été à la fac, vous avez
rencontré des géopolitologues, vous avez
rencontré des gens de l'armée, vous avez
rencontré quoi ? Ben en fait, j'ai fait
des j'ai d'abord rencontré un professeur
de géopolitique qui s'appelle
Jean-Antoine Dupra. Euh enfin, c'est pas
un professeur de géopolitique, mais
c'est un professeur en tout cas
d'histoire et cetera où j'avais
rencontré un peu par hasard sur un salon
du livre et puis euh et puis je lui
expliqué un petit peu que j'étais dans
une démarche, que j'allais écrit un
nouveau spectacle et que j'avais besoin
de cours d'histoire, de géographie et
cetera et cetera et puis euh on a été
resté un petit peu en contact et donc du
coup lui il a commencé à me donner des
cours. Euh alors les les cours vraiment
je moi je veux vraiment travailler de
manière chronologique parce que je pense
que c'est important de de la même
manière que j'écris de manière
chronologique. Je quand j'écris un
spectacle, je peux pas si je bloque sur
le début, j'écris pas une vanne du
milieu et tout parce que pour moi pour
qu'un spectacle soit cohérent, il faut
que la pensée soit cohérente et une
pensée découle toujours d'une autre
pensée. Alors je pense que pour arriver
à garder une sincérité et cetera, faut
travailler de manière chronologique dans
dans dans ce qu'on fait. Euh donc j'ai
vraiment repris euh les bases euh
vraiment les bases de l'histoire et j'ai
commencé au plus loin possible et puis
au fur et à mesure j'ai avancé et en
parallèle de ça effectivement j'avais
toute une bibliographie euh à lire. euh
la bibliographie euh j'ai j'ai pris
conseil auprès de plein de gens
différents parce que c'est ça aussi le
truc, c'est que je me dis toujours que
quelle que soit la personne que j'ai en
face de moi, de toute façon euh elle a
sa propre façon de voir les choses et
moi ce que je veux c'est avoir plein de
points de vue différents pour essayer,
je dis bien essayer d'être au maximum
objectif. Donc, j'avais une
bibliographie, certains bouquins qui a
été conseillés par mon prof, d'autres
par des journalistes, d'autres par des
journalistes de guerre, d'autres par des
amis, d'autres donc voilà. Et ensuite,
une fois que j'avais un petit peu de
matière, j'avais une petite idée
générale de des sujets que je voulais
traiter, euh là, j'ai fait des
rencontres. Donc si je prenais un thème
ou un sujet, n'importe quoi, et puis
j'essayais de de savoir qui je pouvais
rencontrer, qui pouvait m'en dire plus.
Donc j'ai rencontré des photographes de
guerre, des des journalistes, j'ai
rencontré des des certains politiques,
j'ai rencontré effectivement des des des
militaires aussi. Euh donc j'ai fait
tout un tas de rencontres comme ça était
plus ou moins enrichissante mais en tout
cas euh toujours quand même il y a il y
a des gens il y a des gens que j'ai
rencontré qui m'ont pas forcément
apporté quelque chose dans le contenu
mais qui par contre m'ont m'ont dans
l'énergie qu'ils avaient dans dans ce
qui dégageait euh m'ont permis aussi de
ressentir certaines choses parce que
quand on parle de la guerre c'est très
compliqué il faut
c'est c'est déjà vachement dur de monter
sur scène. On a peur et c'est bon après
personne nous a forcé. Je veux dire
c'est un très beau métier mais je dire
on a déjà c'est flippant de monter seul
sur scène et quand on a des propos comme
je peux avoir c'est
sont comment les propos ?
Bah les propos on va dire des propos qui
peuvent ne pas plaire à tout le monde
qui peuvent être mal pris qui peuvent
Alors il y a il y a les vannes. Ça les
vanes je les assume parce que ça c'est
c'est mon humour. Après moi je suis pas
un intellectuel. Donc quand on va sur
des sujets comme la comme la la
géopolitique, donc la guerre et cetera,
c'est très compliqué parce que euh
chaque personne a l'impression d'avoir
raison et quelque part ils ont tous
raison parce que euh ils ont un contexte
qui fait que ils ont une argumentation
euh à peu près cohérente. Vous prenez
deux ennemis euh je vous parlez avec un,
le premier, vous dites "Ah [__] c'est
vrai que quand même ce mec a raison."
clairement ce mec a raison parce que lui
c'est vraiment un mec bien puis après
vous avez parlé à l'autre du coup avec
ça un peu d'a priori parce que l'autre
vous a tellement convaincu et vous allez
voir le deuxième pu vous apercevez que
lui aussi c'est un mec bien et puis
après vous étudiez un peu le truc et
vous vous rendez compte que les raisons
pour lesquelles ces deux mecs se font la
guerre sont pas les raisons officielles.
Et et toi tu dis "Mais en fait ce mec
est un mec bien, lui aussi c'est un mec
bien." Quel est l'enfoiré en fait qui a
mis ces deux mecsun l'un en face de
l'autre tu vois ? Alors, parfois de
rencontrer des gens, de ressentir leur
colère ou leur détresse ou hein, ça te
donne de la force pour aller défendre
tes propos sur scène. Parce que si tu si
juste tu donnes ton avis et que tu as lu
dans des livres, c'est bien. Ça te donne
des arguments, ça te donne des mots,
mais ça ne te donne pas le le l'énergie,
tu vois. et et c'est bien d'aller à la
rencontre des gens parce que ça donne de
la force pour pour affronter euh la
scène avec des avec des propos euh qui
peuvent ne pas plaire. Quand quelqu'un
se lève en disant "Je ne suis pas
d'accord", ben toi tu es tu as eu
suffisamment d'énergie autour de toi
pour savoir que tu es en train de faire
quelque chose de bien et de pour pas
pour pas t'écrouler pour
l'éducation populaire.
Pardon ?
C'est de l'éducation populaire.
Je je je crois que l'éducation ne peut
pas être autre chose que populaire.
Pour moi, pour moi, à partir du moment
où quelqu'un ne comprend pas quelque
chose, c'est la personne qui explique
qui est responsable. Euh je je
par exemple quand on dit géopolitique,
euh tu on va pas faire un spectacle sur
la géopolitique, ça n'a pas de sens. On
va pas on peut pas se marrer avec de la
géopolitique. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on a
mis dans la tête des gens que
géopolitique tout de suite ça devait
être hyper compliqué. Pourquoi quand on
dit à un mec géopolitique,
pourquoi ça lui semble tout de suite oh
[__] tu dis n'importe géopolitique,
tu as un recul, tu vois, tu dis "Oh là
là, on a l'impression que c'est pourquoi
on a mis ça à la tête des gens ?
Pourquoi il y a certains thèmes dès que
tu les dès que tu dès que tu en parles,
les gens s'éloignent ? Parce qu'on veut
pas que les gens s'approchent. On n pas
envie que le savoir soit accessible. On
n pas envie de dire aux gens que tout
est simple à comprendre.
Le système, c'est ça qui est bien dans
ce système. On dire le système c'est
vague et le système c'est large. Oui,
c'est c'est vague et c'est large parce
que oui, le système, qu'est-ce que c'est
le système ? J'en sais rien. Qu'est-ce
que c'est le système ? personne peut
vraiment définir le système. En tout
cas, il y a un système qui est là, qui
régit des choses, qui a instauré des
lois. Et ce qui est formidable avec ce
système, c'est que c'est jamais de la
faute de personne. Et de manière
effective, c'est jamais de la faute de
personne. Il y a des contrexemples mais
dans les
on va dire que si si on considère que le
que que ce système a plusieurs couches,
dans les premières couches, vous avez
vraiment des gens qui vous disent "Ce
n'est pas ma faute" parce que c'est
suffisamment les prises de décision sont
suffisamment dispatchées pour que les
personnes qui prennent ces décisions
n'aient pas l'impression que c'est à
cause d'eux qu'il arrive quelque chose.
Donc ils sont avec un tout petit peu de
rationalisation, ils arrivent très bien
à vous dire "Ce n'est pas de ma faute."
Et concrètement oui, c'est pas de leur
faute. Il participent à un truc qui
engendre un autre truc qui engendre un
autre truc qui engendre un autre truc.
Donc c'est c'est à la fois terrifiant et
à la fois
Non, en fait, je crois que c'est juste
terrifiant en fait.
Donc, vous abordez pendant ce spectacle
tout un tas de thèmes. Vous vous crachez
un peu la gueule de tout le monde, de
toutes les les opinions, tout vous leur
marchez à pied joint dessus.
Ça passe déjà par un humour de classe
piquant. C'est les les beauves de
province, ils en prennent pour pour leur
grat quand même un peu. Non,
je sais pas si c'est les beau de
province parce que j'ai j'ai le même
texte à Paris. Donc je je crois que pour
le coup pour pour moi ça c'est des c'est
des notions qui existent pas. Le
pas du classe,
je crois pas. Je je enfin si si tu es un
humoriste de d'une certaine classe, tu
vois. Mais euh moi je vois pas euh je en
fait je déjà les classes si tu veux,
j'ai jamais euh c'est vraiment des je je
te jure hein, c'est pas c'est pas c'est
je dis pas ça pour euh pour faire genre,
je suis très sérieux. C'est pas les
choses qui pour moi existent réellement.
Euh pour moi, tu as juste
non, je sais pas, naïvement quand
j'étais ado, je juste
il y a les pauvres, il y a les riches et
puis et puis il y a ça au milieu tu
vois. Enfin, pour moi, ça s'arrêtait là.
Mais euh je je ce que je veux dire,
c'est que je crois que les classes euh
n'existe euh dans la vie et dans la tête
que de gens qui font partie d'une
classe. Mais je ne crois pas que ça en
fasse une classe. Je crois que ça en
fait une partie de gens qui s'estiment
au-dessus des autres. En fait, je crois
pas qu'il y a de classe. Je crois juste
qu'il y a des mecs qui se la racontent
et qui disent "Nous faisons partie d'une
classe supérieure." Parce que il y a
jamais de mecs qui disent "On fait
partie d'une classe inférieur ?"
D'ailleurs, il y a que ceux qui pensent
faire partie d'une élite qui parlent de
classe. Donc en fait, c'est juste des
communautés qui se la racontent.
Le Bataclan, vous l'abordez dans le
spectacle tout au début. Euh c'est dur
d'aborder ça juste après le Bataclan ?
Est-ce que les gens flippent ? Est-ce
qu'il y a un service de sécurité
particulier ? Est-ce qu'il y a un
service de protection aux personnalités
qui vous suit ? Est-ce que vous avez
reçu des menaces des islamistes ?
Est-ce que vous êtes pour queil y ait
des gens qui surveillent de l'intérieur
vos vos salles de de
Je sais pas si je vais retenir toutes
les questions
de concert. Ouais, c'est ça tombe bien.
J'ai j'ai fait des notes.
Ça ça a été euh
le Bataclan, ça a été bon déjà
évidemment bouleversant
dire comme tout le monde. Enfin je on
peut pas ne pas être bouleversé par ce
qui s'est passé. Donc déjà, c'est un
choc.
Et après, moi je me retrouve bien
emmerdé parce que
3 mois après les attaques, je dois être
sur scène à Paris avec vent de pièces à
Beout. Donc moi, j'ai fini d'écrire le
spectacle, je suis en répétition, je
suis en train de peaufiner mon texte,
d'apprendre. Voilà, c'est un spectacle
sur la guerre, euh sur le terrorisme euh
et cetera. Donc il se passe ça. Je n'ai
aucune autre possibilité que d'en parler
parce que on comprendrait pas pourquoi
j'en parle pas et comment j'en parle.
Parce que moi-même je suis encore quand
même choqué du truc, tu vois
comment moi je trouve le recul pour en
parler et comment comment je comment
faire pour faire rire les gens
là-dessus.
Donc j'avoue que je suis quand même
vachement perdu parce que pendant
plusieurs semaines, je sais pas du tout
quoi faire. Je je sais pas du tout
comment. Alors j'essaie de revenir à la
base de ce que je fais pas que de ce que
je fais de ce que de ce qu'est cet
humour qu'on pe humour noir ou humour
provoque enf on peut app ça comme on
veut et je me dis bon
et je me rappelle d'un truc que je
disais toujours au programmateurs de
télévision de radio au début quand je
démarrais qu'on voulait me censurer ou
qu'on me recevait pas ou quoi
qui voulait vous censurer ? Bah qui
voulait me en fait c'est même pas qui
voulait me censurer, c'est que j'étais
pas reçu du tout. Le le moi le démarrage
c'était très simple, c'est que on me
prenait même pas dans des festival
d'humour. Donc le même des petits
plateaux le samedi dans certains
théâtres où tu as genre 7 humoristes par
semaine, tu vois. Même ça, j'étais
j'étais pas j'étais pas pris. Donc donc
il y avait même pas de censure au
départ. Il y avait juste j'étais pas
j'étais pas invité nulle part.
Et je me rappelle un peu plus tard quand
il y a fallu de temps en temps que je me
batte pour imposer un texte ou pour
quand des fois il y a eu des craintes
sur certains textes et cetera, ce qui
est totalement normal. Je veux dire
toutes les émissions que j'ai travaillé
de temps en temps, il y a eu des gens
qui ont dit "Putain, ça tu es sûr ? On
m'a jamais coupé mais il y a eu des de
temps en temps des discussions, c'est
normal, c'est parti du jeu. Et en fait
mon argument c'est toujours leur dire
mais comprenez en fait que si tu fais
une vanne sur un sujet grave, si tu fais
une vanne qui est méchante, on va dire à
100 %, elle est 100 % méchante, elle est
100 % méchante donc quelque part elle
est crédible, tu vois c'est possible
d'être 100 % méchant à un moment donné.
Donc si tu veux permettre aux gens de
pouvoir rire, il faut que ce soit 200 %
méchant. Parce que si tu es 200 %
méchant, c'est impossible. même la plus
grosse des pourritures, elle va pas
montrer à 200 % qu'elle est une
pourriture. Elle va le montrer à 100 %
mais elle va toujours avoir un petit peu
de retenu. Donc si tu es à 200 %, ça
devient tellement méchant que c'est pas
possible. Donc si c'est pas possible,
c'est absurde. Donc si c'est absurde,
c'est drôle et c'est comme ça que tu
peux faire marrer les gens avec. Alors
que quand tu réduis un peu la voilure et
que tu vas à 80 %, là ça devient très
gênant parce que là tu dis pourquoi il a
80 % ? C'est qu'il y a quelque chose à
se reprocher. Tu vois pourquoi il a
réduit, pourquoi il est gêné ? Donc donc
du coup la démarche elle est pas bonne.
100 % c'est un peu ambigu. 200 % bon
soit tu vas dire "Ah il abuse, ça me
fait pas rire" mais tu vas pas dire le
mec le pense tu vois. Donc c'est donc
c'est ce que j'ai fait avec le bataclan.
J'ai dis OK alors ce que je vais faire
je vais faire le quel est le pire truc
que je puisse faire ? Et ben c'est
d'arriver sur scène de dire aux gens "On
va se faire attaquer c'est sûr. Ce
qu'ils ont fait au Bataclan, le public
s'est très mal comporté. Vous pouvez
faire beaucoup mieux. Je veux être fier
de vous. Je veux que vous mourriez avec
de la classe. Je vais vous expliquer
comment on va faire. Et du coup, je
descends dans la salle, je prends un
spectateur, je le mets chef de sécurité
parce que je dis les gens, il faut
toujours qu'ils aient un chef, ils font
n'importe quoi, je monte et puis là et
là je rentre dans l'absurde. J'imagine
avec le spectateur comment on des armes
un terrorist et cetera et je fais ça
pendant 20 minutes. Pourquoi 20 minutes
? Parce que c'est pareil, j'ai tout
poussé en fait. C'est j'ai dit je vais
tout pourser tout pousser au maximum.
Donc je démarre le spectacle avec je me
moque de ce qui s'est passé comme si
j'en avais rien à [__] mais de la pire
manière qu'il soit. Je leur dis qu'ils
vont mourir. Je prends un mec dans le
public, je le fais monter sur scène, je
lui dis "Tu vas désarmer un terroriste
s'il y a une attaque, c'est toi qui t'en
occupe." Tu vois ? Et j'ai tout poussé
au maximum maximum maximum. Ce qui fait
que je crois que c'est ça qui a marché
parce que je dis pas qu'il y a pas de
gens qui ont été choqués hein. Il y a
des gens évidemment qu'il y a des gens
qui sont choqués. Je dire même moi que
j'ai fini d'écrire le texte, j'étais
choqué. Tu vois, la première fois que
j'ai vu le spectacle en vidéo, je me
rappelle, je dis "Oh [__] quand même
c'est chaud parce que mais tu as pas le
choix, tu vois ? Parce que parce que
sinon quoi en fait ? le moi j'ai fait
une promesse aux gens, j'ai dit
j'essaierai d'être toujours le plus
sincère possible
et le et le plus
j'irais gérer au maximum de ce que je
pense être bien. Euh alors, je me suis
dit que là le maximum c'était ça. Donc
je l'ai fait et et si je et si je
m'étais planté, ben écoute, si ce
soir-là, le premier soir, les gens euh
ne rientaient pas et que et que et que
je je si j'avais senti à ce moment-là un
malaise, j'aurais dit "OK, on coupe et
je récris autre chose". Tu vois ? Et
mais j'ai fait confiance aussi aux gens.
Il faut aussi faire confiance aux gens.
Ils sont pas bêtes, tu vois. Et et je
crois que c'est ce qui s'est passé. Et
en fait comme les gens arrivent dans un
théâtre, se font fouiller, tout le monde
flippe. Je veux dire, quand il y a eu
ça, moi les les ventes se sont arrêtées
netes. J'avais une tournée qui était en
qui était qui était ouverte, tu vois.
Les ventes se sont arrêtées nettes, les
promos ont été annulées parce
qu'évidemment moi je devais faire des
promos pour annoncer le spectacle, un
truc sur le terrorisme. Tout le monde
m'appel, disit "Ben non, pas tu vas pas
venir là parler de ton WMAN Show sur le
terrorisme", tu vois. Donc c'était
c'était vraiment chaud quoi. C'était
c'était vraiment chaud. Donc donc je me
suis dit ben on va c'est c'est
maintenant que tu es nécessaire en fait.
Montre
montre aux gens que tu peux être fort
sur ce truc. Montre-leur que tu es là
pour eux. C'est ça que tu as voulu être.
Alors sois à la hauteur de ce que tu as
promis aux gens et de ce qu'il te
donnent. Soit soit ça. Réfléchis pas et
fais leur confiance. Et voilà. Mais bon,
avant la première, enfin laisse tomber.
Il y avait il y avait un service de
sécurité particulier. Est-ce que le les
services de sécurité intérieure vous ont
contacté ? Est-ce queil y a eu des gens
armés dans la salle pour au cas où ?
Non, on a eu un un service de sécurité
qui était renforcé bien sûr euh parce
que dans tous les théâtres, c'était
renforcé
mais on n pas eu plus. On n pas eu plus
que d'habitude parce que
parce que c'est du hasard.
Comme tu sais que le hasard
peut frapper, tu sais que ce hasard
existe, alors tu fais en sorte si ce
hasard tombe sur toi d'être prêt. Mais
ça reste du hasard. Donc si tu si tu vis
euh en te protégeant en permanence
du maximum qui puisse t'arriver à cause
du hasard,
tu bouges plus en fait. Donc du coup, on
on essaie d'être dans la mesure,
c'estàdire de se dire "Bon, OK, on sait
que on sait que c'est des choses qui
peuvent arriver, donc on se prépare."
Mais on se prépare
comme on se prépare à n'importe quel
autre truc dramatique qui peut arriver,
mais on rentre pas dans une paranoï.
Parce que si on rentre dans une
paranoïa,
ça desserre tout.
Est-ce que Est-ce que le Bataclan, c'est
le résultat de notre politique
extérieure mégalomane, schizophrénique,
agressive ? Je crois que il n'y a jamais
une seule euh
il y a jamais il y a jamais une seule
raison. Il y a jamais une seule
C'est toujours une multitude de choses.
Il y a il y a je crois que c'est ça le
problème souvent.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de la politique
étrangère française ?
Je pense que bah c'est une question très
vague parce que ça dépend sur quel
sujet, ça dépend à quelle époque, ça
dépend Ah ben l'Arabie Saoud, je le dis
clairement dans le spectacle. Euh pour
moi, on peut pas euh on peut pas euh
on peut pas accepter avec ce qui se
passe là-bas. On peut pas accepter que
ces gens soient le nus. Euh on peut pas
accepter de leur remettre une légion
d'honneur et cetera.
C'était bien avant l'affaire Cachogi en
plus le spectacle.
Oui. Oui. Bien avant bien avant. Parce
que le le problème en fait c'est
le problème en fait c'est que c'est qu'à
force à force de mentir aux gens, à
force d'être toujours en fait en train
de les manipuler de leur tu la légende
d'honneur Hollande c'est presque c'est
presque si c'est presque si il l'a pas
caché en lui mettant en lui serrant la
main comme ça pour pas qu'on la voit
enfin je le
en fait tu peux pas être en permanence
en train de taxer les gens de leur
prendre leur liberté, de les accuser, de
les culpabiliser. En fait, on ne fait
que ça. On tu culpabilises les gens en
permanence. Tu sais quand j'ai commencé
à faire les sketch sur les handicapés à
télévision avec les handicapés, c'était
aussi pour ça. Je comprenais pas comment
tu pouvais être en permanence en train
de culpabiliser les gens, tu sais, leur
mettre une pub en en en montrant un
enfant qui a pas de jambe et et en lui
disant "Et toi, tu peux faire du vélo ?
Alors, donne." Mais [__] mais laisser
les gens tranquilles. Tu es pas obligé
d'aller chercher ces trucs-là pour que
les gens donnent. Les gens sont gentils,
les gens sont généreux. Il y a des il y
a des [__] il y a des racistes, il
y a les homophobes, il y a des misogyes,
mais [__] ils sont pas ils sont pas
ils sont pas majoritaires. C'est pas
parce qu'ils sont minoritaires qu'il
faut pas se battre contre eux. C'est ce
que je fais, tu vois à ma petite de ma
petite manière. Mais arrêtons arrêtons
en permanence de de [__] les gens.
C'est quand même une une
Qui c'est qui les nique ? Mais ce [__]
de système, ce système, ce système, ce
système et les responsables sont ceux
qui sont dans ce système qui le qui le
dirige ou qui le font ou qu'il le
commandent
quoi qu'ils en disent. À partir du
moment, la neutralité dans un système
qui détruit les autres, c'est pas de la
neutralité. Donc quand à un moment donné
tu sors de chez toi, tu prends ta
bagnole, tu te fais tu te fais tu tu
payes, tu passes à un parcm, tu payes,
tu rentres chez toi, tu vas dans un par
terrain, tu payes, tu ouvres ta vite
parce que machin, tu payes, tu as pété
un truc, tu payes. Tu fais en fait que
en permanence
taxé et en contrepartie, on te
culpabilise, on t'enlève tes libertés.
Comment ?
par un milliard de petites choses. Tu
sais, par exemple, on dit des fois sur
sur par exemple,
c'est déjà arrivé qu'on me dise
"Ah oui, mais c'est aussi aux gens
d'aller chercher l'information.
C'est aussi aux gens de se bouger,
d'aller chercher
Ça c'est trop facile de dire ça parce
que
quand est-ce qu'ils font ça les gens en
fait ? Quand tu boses dans une usine et
que ton boulot
dans une mine
dans une mine et que ton boulot par
exemple c'est de trier les boulons. Tu
fais ça toute la journée. C'est pas le
truc le plus épanouissant mais tu le
fais. Tu peux quand même être fur de ton
taf et tout tu vois. Mais genre c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est quand même
difficile. Tu fais ça, tu gagnes, tu
dalle. On va dire c'est des mago. J'en
ai rien à branler en fait. J'en ai en
fait ça les gens qui me traitent de
démago en permanence, j'en ai vraiment
rien à [__] parce que je pense que la
démagogie ça devrait être une une
philosophie de vie. Ça devrait être ça
devrait être obligatoire la démagogie
parce que souvent quand même ça te
permet quand même de te rappeler de te
rappeler quand même des bases qui sont
assez fondamentales. Le donc ce mec il
fait ça toute la journée,
il doit prendre le bus ou je sais pas
quoi. Il a 1 heure et de bus pour
rentrer chez lui, travaille de nuit,
j'en sais rien. Enfin voilà. Et ce
mec-là avec
ta vie de merde quoi.
Ouais, une vie compliquée comme ça. Et
ce mec-là,
il a
parce qu'il s'occuper des enfant
s'occuper Ouais. Il a des en tant
qu'homme, il a plein de choses à faire.
Donc il a allez il a 3h le samedi
pour faire des
Je crois que qu'est-ce qu'il a comme
comme possibilité pour aller chercher
l'information ? Il a quoi ? La presse.
Non, de toute façon, la presse, elle te
dit ce que ce que tu as envie
d'entendre. La télévision, on peut pas
trop faire confiance non plus. On sait
que il y a des trucs vrais, il y a des
trucs pas vrais. Donc alors comment tu
fais le tri ? Parce que lui il a que 3h.
Il a 3h, il peut prendre de
l'information mais il a pas le temps de
faire le tri. Il a pas le temps. Puis
samedi d'après de toute façon
l'information elle a changé. Donc voilà.
Donc il trouve où le temps en fait ? Il
va où ? Il va il va acheter un bouquin à
bibliothèque, un truc à 20 balles mais
il peut pas. Il peut pas. Les 20 € il a
besoin pour autre chose. Donc il peut
pas. Donc qu'est-ce qui lui reste comme
choix ? Aré ou ou de la presse
totalement intello et élitiste ? On
comprend que dalle quand on lit le truc.
Donc l'information elle soit
inaccessible, soit totalement embrumée
dans des mots totalement
incompréhensibles par cette classe dont
on parlait tout à l'heure d'intellectuel
qui estime que c'est à toi d'aller
chercher la définition du mot et si tu
as pas le temps de le faire ben c'est
c'est que tu mérites de travailler dans
une usine et puis d'être dans ta vie.
Donc ce que je veux dire c'est que de
toute façon on fait en sorte que les
gens n'aient pas le temps ou pas
l'énergie ou pas l'envie et je les
comprends d'aller chercher
l'information.
Donc qu'est-ce qui te reste ? Tu es à
l'école,
on te dit
tu fais tes études et puis alors tu
arrives en en 4e en 3e là commence à te
dire qu'est-ce que tu veux faire dans la
vidéo ? J'en sais rien. J'ai 14 ans, 13
ans, 12 ans, j'ai un bébé. Qu'est-ce que
j'en sais ? Alors nous on va te dire
déjà par rapport à tes notes, tu vas
aller dans telle catégorie. Mais
attendez parce que moi ce que je
voudrais c'est être mathématicien. C'est
être j'en sais rien, je veux être
astrophysicien mais pas du tout.
Benjamin, n'importe quoi, tu as 8 en
math, tu as 17 en français, tu vas aller
en L. Mais il a 8 en math là maintenant.
Peut-être que quand tu lui donnes de
l'astrophysique, il va avoir 19 en math.
On nen sait rien, tu vois. Mais déjà dès
le départ, on te met dans des classes.
On te dit toi tu vas en L, toi tu vas en
S, toi tu vas en ES, toi tu vas en
machin. Personne comprend rien ce que ça
veut dire. Mais bon, tu te retournes
dans un truc où tu es obligé de faire
quelque chose. Alors évidemment ce
système de de qui partitionne comme ça
déjà, c'est dramatique, mais c'est pas
ça qui est grave. Ce qui est grave,
c'est qu'en fait on dit dès le départ
aux gens qu'il faut éviter l'échec.
C'est ça qui est dramatique, c'est qu'en
gros, on te dit "Mais Benjamin,
en France, en France,
en France, oui, bien sûr Benjamin, mais
pourquoi est-ce que tu veux aller faire
des maths puisque regarde, tu as 8 en
math,
tu vois ? Donc on te met dans la tête
que il faut suivre la facilité et ce
pourquoi tu as soit-disant des
aptitudes. On te dit on t'explique pas
du tout que peut-être que plus tard si
un sujet t'intéresse, tu peux être le
meilleur dedans et cetera. Non non non.
On te dit il faut éviter l'échec en
permanence. Éviter l'échec. Moi je
trouve que ça c'est une erreur. Éviter
l'échec. Apprendre à nos enfants à
éviter l'échec. Je pense que c'est une
connerie. Il faut il faut avoir des
échecs. C'est important. Il faut pas
forcer les gens à être dans une réussite
parce que si tu forces les gens à être
dans une réussite permanente, il y en a
beaucoup qui vont choisir la facilité
parce qu'ils vont avoir l'impression que
s'ils ont une fois un échec,
ils vont porter l'échec sur leur visage
à vie. C'est pour ça qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui ne tentent rien.
C'est pour ça qu'il y a tant de gens qui
j'aurais dû, j'aurais pu et cetera.
Euh, on parle un petit peu de
l'investissement responsable de la
grosse Christine, de d'assaut, des
produits financiers. C'est une histoire
vraie, c'est pas une histoire vraie.
C'est quoi ?
Non, c'est pas une histoire vraie.
Euh
non, c'est pas une histoire vraie. Ce
qui se passe, c'est que effectivement
dans le spectacle, je raconte que c'est
le point de départ où je dis qu'en gros,
j'ai commencé à gagner de l'argent, moi
je sais pas quoi en faire.
J'en sais rien. J'en sais rien parce que
tout dépend ce que tu appelles
Mais attends, ça dépend en fait de ce
que tu appelles gagner parce que euh
tu as ce qui rentre dans une société
et tu as ce qui rentre pour toi.
Tu payes tes impôts en France ?
Oui, bien sûr. Bah où d'autres ? au
Luxembourg, en Suisse. Mais
j'ai pas de contact pour faire ça.
Je j'ai pas les Non, j'ai pas les réseau
pour faire ça. Le moi la la grande
grande majorité de de la Non, mais en
plus, tu vas croire que tu vas je te
jure que tu vas croire que que je veux
pas te répondre, mais je te jure que je
ne sais pas euh parce que en fait la je
crois vraiment que je mens pas en disant
que je pense que 80 % de ce que je gagne
reste dans ma société et parce que je
suis vraiment un entrepreneur. Donc donc
la plupart de l'argent que je gagne va
dans ma société pour en ouvrir d'autres,
pour monter des projets, produire des
artistes et cetera et cetera. Après moi
j'ai acheté une maison, la première
chose que j'ai fait quand j'ai commencé
à gagner un peu d'argent, c'est acheté
une maison à ma mère. Après, j'en ai
acheté une pour moi, mais c'est récent,
ça fait 2 ans, tu vois. Donc avant,
j'étais encore locataire et cetera. J'ai
pas vraiment de délire de luxe, tu vois.
Pour l'instant, j'ai pas de bagnole là,
j'ai pas de j'ai rien de cher et tout
ça. Moi mon plaisir, c'est vraiment les
les voyages voyager parce que je sois
hyper enrichissant puis j'ai pas pu
voyager quand j'étais plus jeune. Donc
voilà. Et vraiment entreprendre, ça
c'est un grand kiff. C'est de pouvoir
mettre 50000 800000 € dans un truc en
disant allez là on va on va on va mettre
de l'argent sur la table pour tenter
quelque chose que les autres n'ont pas
tenté. tout ce que je montre, tout ce
qu'on essaie de faire, je dis on parce
que c'est aussi toute mon équipe qui est
avec moi euh dont Michaell euh qui est
avec moi depuis le départ et ben on
essaie de monter des choses où on se dit
"On espère que ça va marcher, mais on
veut toujours qu'il y ait un truc un peu
humain dedans, tu vois.
On s'est imposé ça. Quand je dis quand
je dis qu'on s'est imposé ça, c'est
important parce que on est tous pareil.
On a tous des fois,
je veux dire, on peut avoir envie de
gagner de l'argent hyper facilement. On
on peut moi-même, je peux avoir des fois
des mauvaises pensées et dire "Putain,
si je faisais ça là, ça serait simple de
ramasser un gros chèque. Je peux machin
donc tu sais ce qu'on fait ? On dit haut
effort, on est hyper honnête comme ça.
On est obligé d'être honnête." Donc on
s'est on s on a vraiment fait spact avec
Michael quand on a monté les boîtes au
départ, la boîte au départ. On s'est dit
on va s'il y en a un qui fléchit, l'eau
doit le rattraper. Et on essaye, je dis
pas qu'on le fait à chaque fois hein,
peut-être qu'en creusant tu trouves des
trucs, tu vois. Mais je crois vraiment
que la majorité du temps, on essaie de
faire un truc qui est à la fois humain
et à la fois euh
responsable.
Voilà. En tout cas, jamais faire un truc
que pour le business.
On essae. Et en plus, il se trouve que
ça marche parce que du coup, tu fais des
trucs originaux qui fonctionnent. Donc
euh parce que c'est fait avec le cœur,
parce que voilà
la grosse Christine
euh Ah oui alors l'histoire du
financier. Donc en gros ce qui se passe
c'est que euh
d'ailleurs pourquoi la grosse Christine
une blague grossophobe dans franchement
pas du tout les en fait je prends
toujours des prénoms comme ça déjà donc
je ne sais pas je connais même pas je
crois même pas connaître vraiment une
Christine euh mais non c'est c'est
vraiment c'est des trucs qui dans la
tête parce que ça m'amuse dire la grosse
Christine ça m'amuse mais il y a pas
vraiment de il y a pas vraiment moi il y
a il y a plein de trucs où où il y a pas
de sens
même le titre du spectacle quel rapport
avec vent de pièces à verrou quel
rapport avec votre spectacle je ne sais
pas moi.
Je crois juste que ça me faisait marrer
d'imaginer un mec qui qui qui fait du
business dans un lieu où il y a eu la
guerre ou en après-guerre. Enfin voilà,
tu vois, c'est des trucs un petit peu
abstraits comme ça. Et grosse Christine,
c'est venu comme ça. Tu ça se trouve
j'ai croisé une Christine dans
l'après-midi, une grosse le soir et puis
j'ai fait une association. J'ai dit
tiens appelle ça grosse Christine, il y
a pas vraiment de but. Mais par contre,
non, c'est ça, c'est que je me suis euh
comme c'était le 2e spectacle que je
suis passé euh euh de de rien gagner à à
gagner bien ma vie. Euh j'ai voulu le
dire aux gens parce que je trouve ça
important.
Tu les remercies d'ailleurs ?
Je les remercie. Euh et puis parce que
c'est pareil, il faut être vraiment dans
la sincérité. Je vais pas continuer à
dire euh que je bos chez Orange, tu
vois, ça n'a pas de sens. Donc euh et
donc quand euh moi je suis moi quand
j'ai commencé à gagner de l'argent, je
me suis retrouvé c'était quand même
drôle parce que euh le dernier appel que
j'avais eu de ma banque euh tu sais un
peu un appel en urgence comme ça pas
programmé, c'était pour me dire faut
remettre de l'argent les agioot machin
je sais pas quoi et euh que je crois 6
ou 7 mois plus tard, j'ai un appel de la
même personne qui me dit "Faudit que
vous passiez et tout, qu'on parle de vos
placements." Et donc j'ai dit "Putain,
je suis vraiment en train de vivre ce
cliché, tu sais. tu as vraiment le même
mec qui en 6 mois t'appelle pour te dire
un coup et [__] mec bien payé là
machin
euh ce qui est absurde d'ailleurs parce
que même quand tu réfléchis au principe
des agio c'est quand même c'est quand
même complètement absurde et le même
t'appelle 6 mois après pour te dire le
placement et puis du coup ça m'a fait
marrer et je me suis et et je me
rappelle avec Michel on se marie mais
qu'est-ce que il me dit on voudrait
votre on voudrait votre savoir dans quoi
vous voudriez placer votre argent mais
le mec croit que je sais dans quoi on va
placer notre argent que enfin moi moi je
connaissais le livret déjà j'en avais
pas ouvert
de moi ça me stresser déjà avoir un
livret A je comprenais pas j'avais
l'impression qu'on essaie de m'en fumer
pourquoi vous voulez retirer mon argent
de mon compte courant ça c'est mon
compte courant ça c'est à moi je peux le
tirer pourquoi vous voulez le mettre
ailleurs je croyais que le mec essayait
de me [__] avec un livret donc si tu
veux plus tu plus tu me parlais de
placer de l'argent ailleur plus j'avais
l'impression juste que tu étais en train
de me l'enlever cétais très basique. Et
donc je me suis dit [__] mais en fait
tu peux vite te retrouver à placer
finalement sans t'en rendre compte à
placer de l'argent dans des trucs
qui correspondent pas à ce que à ton
éthique tu vois. Et du coup c'est parti
là. J'ai ça serait un bon thème de ça
sera un bon thème de démarrage.
Je te coupe je te coupe. On on rappelle
à nos podcasteurs qui nous écoutent que
euh il y a Tipi ce mois-ci surtout 7h
qui va doubler nos vos dons euh pendant
1 heure ce soir euh la première heure en
direct. Donc si vous voulez mettre des
tipis, il y a des il y a Tipis qui
double Tip. Je te reprends à toi. Les
investissements responsables d'assaut,
les 2
combien de pourcent que qu'une OG qu'une
qu'une ONG euh a ?
Oui, il y a des Je raconte dans le
spectacle effectivement que euh j'ai
plus les chiffres exacts en tête hein
euh dans le spectacle, ils y sont. Mais
effectivement, je raconte que euh que
CCFD terre solidaire en fait pas il y a
il y a une ONG qui est CCFD qui a monté
en fait une espèce de banque. Alors, il
passe par le prisme de d'une autre d'une
autre boîte dont j'ai oublié le nom et
cette boîte là a des placements
financiers dont dont certains chez
d'assauto. Donc tu tr
C'est pas bien.
Bah tu sais, c'est ce que je dis dans le
spectacle. L'éthique c'est propre à
chacun.
Moi personnellement,
on me dit mise ton argent chez moi parce
que je suis une ONG donc ça sera un
placement éthique. Si je sais que
derrière tu investis même 1 € dans une
boîte qui fabrique des armes,
je pense que je vais venir te voir et
que il va falloir que tu m'expliques en
quoi c'est éthique. Mais eux
peuvent te dire tout simplement "Mais
attends, les d'assaut c'est
c'est les éoliennes."
Ouais, c'est les éoliennes. Et puis
voilà. Puis c'est je veux dire c'est une
grosse société française, c'est légal,
notre président se félicite de vendre
des avions, tout va bien. Donc qu'est-ce
que j'en sais si c'est pas éthique ?
Après tout si on regarde si on regarde
de ce qui se passe, ça a l'air éthique
puisqu'on a l'air d'être très fier de
vendre des avions. Puis qu'on a l'air
d'être très fier que cette société
marche bien. On le dit aux infos, on est
tellement content. Oh, notre président
revient, il est content, il a vendu des
avions. Alors, je sais pas, peut-être
c'est éthique, peut-être c'est moi qui
suis trop sensible, je sais pas.
les les ONG dans dans ton spectacle, tu
en parles.
Action contre la INF,
c'est tes copains.
Tu sais que j'ai été leur posé une
question, les gars, ils avaient l'air
tout perturbé.
Ah bon ? Tu leur as demandé quoi ?
Je leur ai demandé s'ils avaient vu ton
spectacle.
Ils l'ont vu.
Ils l'ont vu. Mais
ils t'ont rien dit ?
Bah ils m'ont rien dit. vont
c'est vrai que le président il gagne
10000 €
d'après leur bilan comptable au moment
où j'en parle c'estàd que
dans les années les années dans
lesquelles je parle parce que je cite
les années hein dans dans le spectacle
euh au moment où les faits se passent et
au moment des bilans comptables euh que
que j'ai en main je sais plus parce que
je crois que je parle de 2011 2013 je
parle de plusieurs mais au moment où
j'en parle en tout cas le le patron
c'est ce qui est déclaré en tout cas sur
l'or comptable. Alors si c'est pas vrai,
c'est l'orbillant comptable. C'est pas
moi.
Ils ont changé de locau là aussi.
Depuis je sais pas, je sais pas où ils
sont. Je les ai un peu perdu de vue mais
oui. Non mais il y avait des
représentants d'action contre la fin qui
étaient venu voir le spectacle et
cetera. Après le spectacle, moi je les
avais reçu en lche comme
et puis euh et puis voilà.
On fait comprendre que oui, c'était pas
c'était pas très c'était pas très
chouette de dire ça. Mais moi je je fais
que lire leur bilan comptable, j'ai pas
donné mon avis.
C'est pas moi qui leur qui les force à
Pourquoi tes critiques envers les ONG ?
Parce que je trouve qu'il y a rien de
pire que de se servir
de la bienveillance des gens
pour créer de la malhonnêteté. Je trouve
que c'est vraiment
c'est fort he ce que tu dis. Le pire
truc,
tu sais, c'est comme tu sais c'est la
ligne verte. Tu sais quand John Café, il
tient les petites les petites jumelles
qui sont qui sont qui sont mortes et il
était dans ses bras et il dit il s'est
servi de leur amour pour les tuer. Et
ben, c'est une phrase qui m'a bouleversé
cette phrase et c'est vraiment ça quand
on quand on se sert. C'est pour ça que
je déteste qu'on culpabilise les gens.
Je déteste qu'on les juge. Je c'est dire
les Français mais les mais qui êtes-vous
en fait pour représenter les Français ?
Qui sont ces gens qui disent la France,
la France, la France, les Français ?
Toujours un mec, un mec qui est détesté
par 99 % de la France qui dit "Sachez
que les Français, mais ferme ta gueule,
tu ne représentes pas les Français, tu
ne représentes rien du tout. C'est pas
parce que tu as une colonne dans un
journal où tu vends 2000 exemplaires."
Ces gens s'octroient la parole des
Français et je trouve ça,
tu parles des journalistes là ou des
politiques ? des deux euh pas tous les
tous les politiques et pas tous les
journalistes, mais quand même, je suis
désolé,
à partir de quel moment on a on arrive à
se planter devant une caméra en disant
je pense que les Français, je pense que
la France déjà
déjà soit élu avec une majorité de voix,
une vraie majorité pas on t'a pas on a
coupé en trois, on t'a forcé à choisir
entre ces ces trois là puis après on a
refait un autre truc qui fait que tu as
pas le choix que de voter entre ces
trois-là et puis les votes blancs on les
compte pas et puis machin et puis on
arrive à difficilement
on arrive à te donner un 51 %
je représente la France
tu votes quoi
je vote pas
pas blanc
non bah non il compte pas les votes
pas ça c'est qu'est-ce que j'ai un ou
d'autres trucs à faire le dimanche.
Donc pour revenir sur les ONG, euh tu as
étudié combien d'ONG, combien de bils de
comptable ? Euh c'est tu as découvert
des petits loulous qui se qui se
mettaient plein les poches ou pas du
tout ? Oui oui, j'ai découvert plein de
trucs. Maintenant, je vais pas les dire
là, pas parce que j'ai pas parce que
j'ai peur de dire des trucs, mais parce
que tout simplement euh je ne parle que
des trucs que j'ai vraiment vraiment
bien étudié parce que
parce que je veux garder le crédit que
j'ai auprès des gens et je préfère que
des gens me disent "Ah mais oui, c'est
facile de pas répondre et tout." Je je
je crois que on ne se permet pas assez
par exemple en télévision de dire je ne
sais pas ou je n'ai pas envie de
répondre à la question tu sais parce que
quand un journaliste se pose une
question tu te sens obligé de répondre
tu as l'impression que tu as un devoir
de répondre mais non tu peux dire je ne
sais pas tu vois tu as le droit de dire
je ne sais pas je connais pas le sujet
j'ai pas assez étudié alors pour les ONG
je peux quand même répondre un peu pour
les ONG oui j'ai découvert que
par exemple quand quand une ONG fait des
fait des fait des envois de dons par
courrier
On estime que
il faut à peu près 3 ans pour
rentabiliser l'investissement.
Quel
quelle ONG quelle société peut se
permettre de perdre de l'argent pendant
3 ans avant de rentabiliser un projet ?
Donc ma question c'est
comment ces organisations non
gouvernementales
font-elles pour avoir
ce pouvoir et cette puissance financière
et cette liberté cette liberté de de de
tout cette liberté de enf sont des gens
très libres ils vont où ils veulent ils
vont même là où personne d'autre ne va
ils arrivent quand même à accompagner
des journalistes sur des zones où on ne
peut pas aller sans l'autorisation des
gouvernements et tout en étant non
gouvernemental. Ça c'est très fort. Son
sont sont des sont ils ont sont des gens
qui qui
arrivent d'après d'après ce qu'on nous
dit à rester neutre. C'est quand un
quand un pays euh X ou Y euh euh a
soi-disant un président élu
démocratiquement et de l'autre côté un
sanguinaire, malade, psychopathe et que
et que un pays euh soutient un pays
occidental soutient la partie du
président démocratique, euh ben cette
ONG euh cette ONG euh elle généralement
elle ne va que dans cette partie-là.
Mais mais c'est c'est un c'est un
hasard, c'est juste que c'est très
difficile d'accès de l'autre côté, mais
ils sont neutres. Alors alors il ils
soutiennent moralement en tout cas
l'autre parti, mais généralement il
reste là. Euh mais tout ça c'est tout ça
c'est du c'est du hasard. Le je je moi
je dis simplement que
les ONG
quand on voit un peu quel profil de gens
les dirigent, quand on voit
c'est quel type de profil,
ben c'est souvent des profils qui sont
quand même très proches des profils euh
de de de d'hommes politiques ou d'hommes
euh ou de ou de personnages de de
l'industrie ou ce que je dire c'est que
c'est souvent des profils euh j'ai j'ai
c'est dommage que j'ai plus en tête
exactement Mais je me rappelle qu'on
avait fait un petit travail là-dessus.
on avait regardé un petit peu quels
étaient les dirigeants des des
différentes euh ONG, des grosses ONG
parce que ça c'est important aussi he je
parle des grosses grosses ONG là je je
la plupart est pas toutes he il y en a
aussi des il y en a aussi franchement
des gros ONG où j'ai rien trouvé de de
bizarre mais on va dire souvent dans les
grosses grosses ONG on remarque quand
même que les dirigeants souvent enfin
c'est quand même rarement un mec qui euh
euh
je tu vois C'est r c'est rarement un
c'est rarement un mec comme moi, tu
vois. C'est rarement un mec comme moi.
C'est souvent des gens quand même qu'on
fait c'est c'est souvent des gens qui
ont des curlus des curlus des curlus ça
n'existe pas. On peut même pas regarder
sur dans les dictionnaires qui ont
souvent des cursus qui sont proches de
gens qui deviennent euh des politiciens.
C'est souvent des gens qu'on qu'on des
voix ou qui ou des anciens politiques ou
des ou des c'est pas c'est pas des gens
qu'on a beaucoup vu euh dans des
risières.
euh en train de en train de travailler
dans le champ avec des avec des paysans
locaux pour comprendre leur souffrance
quand même. Rarement, c'est quand même
rarement ça. Mais bon,
Paul Paul Watson Paul Watson, si Shepard
ça te parle
euh
le pirate des mers.
Ouais. Alors, quand je demande aux gens
les ONG qui sur lesquels ils ont donné,
c'est c'est un c'est un nom qui revient
souvent.
D'accord.
Mais j'ai pas j'ai pas étudié leur leur
truc
euh sur les ONG. Des choses à rajouter,
il faut continuer de donner. Il faut pas
continuer de donner, il faut se
renseigner avant. Est-ce qu'il faut
donner à l'aquarius ? Tu connais
l'aquarius ? moimême c'est pareil, j'ai
pas
j'ai pas trop creusé le truc. Mais
moi ce que moi ce que je pense
qu'il faut que les gens donne
en étant réellement intéressé euh par le
sujet parce que si tu es réellement
intéressé par le sujet pour ou la cause,
tu es vraiment passionné par la cause à
laquelle tu vas faire un don,
normalement tu peux éviter de donner un
don qui peut-être n'arrivera jamais là
où tu penses que qu'il va arriver. Euh
peut-être ça vaut le coup aussi de se
tourner euh vers les petites ONG. Il y a
énormément de petites ONG qui ne peuvent
pas se permettre par exemple de faire
des appels au dons parce qu'ils n'ont
pas les moyens de hein et qui sont sur
place. Il y a des il y a énormément
d'ONG, c'est dommage, j'en ai pas en
tête là, mais euh il y a énormément
énormément d'ONG. Si quelque chose vous
touche, si un sujet vous touche, une
cause vous touche, au lieu d'aller
directement sur une ONG, peut-être ne
regardez pas le premier lien que va vous
proposer votre moteur de recherche.
Peut-être simplement
renseignez-vous sur qui est sur place,
qui est là-bas et aider quelqu'un
là-bas. Aidez plutôt un mec local qui a
monté un truc là-bas parce que des fois
vous retrouvez, il y a plein de petites
ONG, ils sont deux tro 4, des fois c'est
un mec tout seul ou un couple et ils
sont sur place avec les gens et souvent
ça a plus d'impact. On parle de la
liberté d'expression.
Allez.
Est-ce qu'il faut être nombreux pour
avoir une certaine liberté d'expression
?
C'està-dire,
est-ce qu'il faut avoir un groupe
derrière toi, une communauté qui te
permet d'être derrière pour maintenir ta
liberté d'expression ? Dans ton
spectacle, tu dis "Merci au public parce
que c'est grâce à vous, vous êtes
nombreux derrière nous, derrière moi.
C'est ce qui me permet d'avoir cette
liberté d'expression."
Alors ouais mais quand je parle de moi
et mon public, on n'est pas un groupe,
on est des des individuel
qui nous rassemblons pour pour se marier
et euh
et moi je viens leur proposer un truc.
Voilà, j'ai réfléchi à ça. Je vous
propose, ils aiment ou ils aiment pas.
Après, je pense que
la liberté d'expression, si tu défends
en fait le le c'est pour ça que je dis
moi je fais partie d'aucun groupe, aucun
groupeuscule, aucun réseau de pensée et
cetera parce que le problème c'est que
quand tu fais partie d'un groupe de
pensée, ça peut être politique, ça peut
être que culturel, ça peut être
idéologique, ça peut être religieux, peu
importe,
tu es obligé de composer un peu parce
que tu as un groupe, tout le monde ne
peut pas penser exactement la même
chose. C'est veut dire que donc pour
être dans un groupe, tu es obligé de
dire "OK bon ça, OK ça, je suis pas
d'accord mais bon c'est pas grave" et on
va dire que tu es majoritairement
d'accord avec la majorité des propos et
des idées qui sont données dans ce
groupe. Et donc de là tu dis "Je fais
partie d'une équipe, d'un groupe et donc
on est fort parce qu'on est plein à
défendre la même idée. Moi je pense que
tu t'affaiblis en faisant ça parce que
parce qu'un groupe un vrai groupe sont
des gens
qui acceptent de ne pas être d'accord et
qui se donnent un objectif commun. Pas
des gens qui se mettent d'accord sur une
idée commune pour atteindre un objectif.
Je je crois vraiment qu'un qu'un groupe
c'est la liberté et que
tu sais tout est comme ça dans la vie.
Quand on dit "Si tu veux quelque chose,
faut pas le chercher.
Tu veux tu veux tu veux que ta femme
revienne, ne lui cours pas après." Tu tu
parce que et en fait c'est simplement
que
tu n'enfermes pas une pensée. Tu tu ne
peux pas faire ça. Donc à partir du
moment où tu défends une idée commune,
tu es forcément dos à un mur. C'est tu
es forcément tu vas regarder comme ça et
tu auras toujours ton groupe qui va te
dire "Attention attention ça tu peux pas
dire ça, tu peux pas dire ça, tu peux
pas dire". C'est pour ça que les hommes
politiques ne peuvent pas être sincères.
peuvent pas être sincères parce que ils
doivent défendre une idée commune,
une stratégie,
une idéologie. On est obligé, on choisit
un axe. De quoi
politique ? Ils ont une stratégie en ce
moment.
Oui, mais elle fonctionne. Leur
stratégie, elle est simple, c'est juste
de rester au pouvoir.
Non, aucune autre stratégie
juste de rester au pouvoir. Il faut
qu'on reste au pouvoir. Alors, comment
on fait ?
On va faire deux groupes droite gauche
qui va où ? Voilà et puis de toute façon
c'est les mecs sont allés à l'école
ensemble. Donc dès le départ, ben c'est
vrai. Donc voilà, je veux dire, moi je
sais pas
quand un mec comme Fillon par exemple
dit euh à la télé que
je suis à la tête d'un prés d'un pays en
faillite.
Ouais. Bon, déjà, il était à la tête de
rien
et puis euh et puis bah, il avait pas
tort pour la faillite. Mais mais tu
sais, je suis pas je suis pas exactement
sûr de des propos exacts, hein. Donc,
pas la peine de s'acharner sur moi. Je
dis dès le départ, je lui dis un truc un
peu approximatif, mais je sais qu'il a
il a parlé de de l'IVG et il a parlé des
droits des homosexuels et qui remettait
un petit peu en cause les libertés
établies sur ces deux sujets.
Je sais plus de quelle manière, mais
bon, il avait dit deux trois, il a tenu
deux trois propos là-dessus. Quand moi
j'entends ça, je me dis donc
ce mec, l'IVG et le droit
des homosexuels sur les enfants et
cetera,
il est pas il a pas dit clairement, je
vais parce qu'il des problèmes, mais
nous a quand même fait comprendre qu'il
était pas 100 % chaud pour tout ce qui
se passe en ce moment. Donc
si par exemple on donne comme thème de
d'une soirée d'un dîner par exemple, on
invite deux personnes Fran Fillon et on
met Marine Le Pen et on dit la seule
chose dont vous avez le droit de parler
ce soir c'est de l'IVG et des droits
homosexuels. Ils vont passer une très
bonne sole
vachement d'accord sur plein de trucs.
Et alors et après comment on m'explique
si
une personne est capable
de sous-entendre que
une femme parce qu'elle est une femme ou
une personne
de par sa sexualité n'a pas le droit ou
ne devrait pas ou il trouve que
peut-être c'est comme ça mais c'est pas
très bien d'avoir les mêmes droits que
n'importe quel autre être humain.
Comment cette personne peut-elle être
humaniste
envers des inconnus, envers des
étrangers ?
C'est pas possible, tu vois, parce que
ne serait-ce qu'en temps comme
à peu près la moitié de ton entourage,
ça va être des femmes, c'est déjà
testime donc ta mère, ta sœur, ta femme
des bon enfin si tu estimes déjà que
c'est que c'est que ces personnes qui
sont gentille dont une qui t'a mise au
monde que bon ce droit qu'on lui
accorde,
ça fait un petit peu chier quand même.
Je veux dire comment cette personne elle
peut être humaniste et dans la
générosité de penser dans l'ouverture
d'esprit sur les autres sujets ? C'est
impossible. Les migrants qu'est-ce que
tu en penses ?
Je trouve ça
tu vois Nicolas Dupignan posé devant les
barbelets de d'Orbane.
Mais moi ça me fait trop rire. Mais en
fait
il il y a un tel degré de
tu sais ça me fait penser à tu sais à
ton oncle gênant au karaokeé qui veut
chanter du dy rossos tu vois c'est que
c'est tellement absurde
tu vois il va chanter mal tu vas pas
juste dire tu vas pas juger ton oncle en
disant qu'est-ce qu'il chante mal c'est
dramatique fa quand même lui dire non
juste tu rigoles en fait quand je vois
des choses comme ça c'est tellement
décalé c'est tellement
Ça n'a tellement rien à voir avec les
gens, c'est tellement absurde que il tu
peux que rire parce que c'est ce qui est
dangereux, c'est les gens qui arrivent à
être crédible, qui arrivent à
convaincre. Ça c'est juste une vanne, tu
vois. Je personne croit, tu vois.
J'espère peut-être quelques personnes
qui y croient, mais des gens de son
groupe à lui, des gens de sa classe,
mais pas je personne c'est tellement
tellement absurde. Euh
ça peut pas convaincre une je crois pas
que ça puisse convaincre une majorité de
gens. J'espère.
Quand tu vois la caravane de Hondurien
qui remonte vers les États-Unis où il y
a 8000 personnes qui ont fait 4000 km à
pied.
J'ai pas j'ai pas trop suivi le truc là.
Voà, il y a il y a 9000 militaires qui
attendent. ou qui a qui sont en train de
réceptionner 8000 pour une demande
d'asile pour échapper à la pauvreté,
la famine, la violence. Bon, toutes ces
ces petites choses que le capitalisme
prédateur nous impose.
Et euh euh les murs, il y en a de plus
en plus des des
gens qui disent que il faut monter des
murs plus haut, plus épais, plus loin,
de plus en plus.
Je sais pas combien il y a de gens qui
disent qu'il faut monter des murs. Plus
en plus là on a même au Brésil
maintenant. Il y en a très certainement
de plus en plus. Il très certainement de
plus en plus. Mais
c'est ridicule. Pourquoi ? Alors
je continue de dire que bah parce que là
tu me parles de du Pontignan et du
Brésil. C'est un c'est un c'est un
raccourci vachement raccourci. Donc euh
donc euh non, tu vois, on est quand même
on est quand même sur des sur des sur
des choses qui sont très très
différentes.
La montée du nationalisme
dans quel pays ?
Tous en France, en en Afrique. En
Afrique, il y en a plein maintenant.
Mais par exemple, si je dis la montée du
nationalisme en France,
pourquoi on parle de monté du
nationalisme en France ?
Les gens ont peur.
Mais de quoi ? Qui les gens ?
De la popérisation. La popérisation de
la classe moyenne.
Mais qui ? La popularisation de la
classe moyenne, on sait même pas ce que
ça veut dire. Moi je comprends même pas.
Moi je suis de la classe moyenne de
départ, je comprends même pas cette
phrase. Alors je sais pas, moi je crois
que moi je crois qu'il y a des il y a la
presse qui marque des titres. Moi j'ai
vu des trucs, des débats. La France
était l'islamophobe. Je vous êtes
sérieux là ? Donc donc à la fin de ce
débat, on va peut-être dire oui
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc ? Tu le
mec, il allume sa télé chez lui, il est
musulmans, il voit ça mais il dit mais
qu'est-ce que
la violence des titres des débats et
cetera ? Je c'est que tout ça encore une
fois ne représente pas pour moi la la
majorité. C'est pas vrai. Après, quand
un pays qui euh
qui aux élections va lire un
représentant extrémiste, est-ce que les
gens votent
pour cet extrémiste ou contre les autres
? Parce que à un moment donné, tu as
la droite et la gauche qui te disent en
permanence que surtout surtout surtout
votez pas pour l'autre partie, mais
surtout ne votez pas pour le pour le
truc de d'extrême droite et là on te on
te culpabilise. Alors là si tu votes
pour lui et on fait pire, c'est qu'à la
fin quand il te reste que Macron et Pen,
on te dit si tu ne votes pas, si tu ne
vas pas voter, c'est et qu'elle est
élue, ce sera ta faute. [__] mais
arrêtez en fait, lâchez-nous quoi. C'est
notre faute. Je veux dire c'est que à un
moment donné quand tu passes ton temps à
promettre des trucs aux gens et à pas
les tenir, quand tu passes ton temps à
[__] les gens, quand tu passes ton
temps à les taxer, à leur enlever leur
liberté, à à les accuser, à les
culpabiliser en permanence, en
permanence, en permanence, et ben à un
moment donné, peut-être que la personne
juste elle vote pas pour elle, elle vote
contre toi parce que toi à un moment
donné, à force de dire cette personne
est mauvaise, cette personne est
mauvaise, la personne elle dit "Tu sais
quoi ? De toute façon, toi toi tu nous
as [__] depuis des années et tu nous
dis que cette personne ça te ferait
chier qu'elle soit élue. Et ben on va on
va voter pour cette personne parce que
pas pour elle juste pour te faire chier
toi. Donc ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est c'est trop facile en fait de
responsabiliser les gens sur des choses
qui nous arrangent et de les
déresponsabiliser sur des choses qui
nous arrangent pas. C'est je je crois
que encore une fois il faut il faut
remettre dans le contexte euh quand
quand on a voté euh quand par exemple
aux États-Unis quand ils ont voté pour
Obama alors c'était le peuple le plus
grand du monde. Quand on voté pour Trump
c'était tous des connards. Non c'est pas
ça. C'est que Obama il a fait aussi
beaucoup de promesses qu'il a pu
difficilement tenir voire pas tenir du
tout. à vous.
Euh ouais, entre autres euh parce que il
y a le conseil parce que machin
finalement bah finalement on est un peu
déçu parce qu'on s'attendait à un truc
et puis bah ça reste un petit peu comme
d'habitude. Donc les gens bah à un
moment donné il ils switchent, il Ah
d'accord. Donc vous vous nous avez
promis mon et merveille, on est déçu, on
vote pour l'autre. Moi je suis pas
certain que les gens que tous les gens
qui ont voté pour Trump c'est en se
disant vite on va monter des murs contre
les Mexicains. Tu vois, je crois pas que
ce soit ça dans la tête des gens. Je
crois que dans la tête des gens, c'est
beaucoup plus simple que ça. Je crois
que les gens juste en ont rat le bol et
après euh et après euh une certaine
classe élitiste qui écrit dans la presse
ou qui fait des gens regarde comme ça le
peuple d'en bas. Ils sont énervés, ils
en ont marre des Mexicains. Le peuple en
a marre des Mexicains mais va les voir
en fait. Va voir en fait. Tu verras
qu'avec ces gens il y a des Mexicains
qui sont qui sont potes avec. Ce que
dire, c'est que tout ça, tout ça, tout
ça, c'est la même chose.
Est-ce que tu peux me parler euh
du royaume des [__] ?
C'est un royaume que j'ai créé.
Alors, il y a un royaume, il y a une
longue liste d'attente,
plein plein de gens qui veulent y
rentrer. Euh non, j'ai essayé de faire
un moment donné dans le spectacle où ça
m'a amusé en fait de faire un
j'ai créé un monde où en fait dans le
spectacle donc quand je découvre que mon
argent va être investi dans l'armement,
je veux faire marche arrière, euh je
veux dire bah je veux plus je veux plus
investir si c'est dans les armes. Puis
ma grosse Christine ma concert me dit
mais
regardez quand même ce que vous allez
gagner et du coup
bon quand même c'est vrai que c'est
c'est quand même bien rémunéré donc je
vais continuer un petit peu. Et donc de
là et tu as laissé ta culpabilité, ta
morale, ton humanité. Euh du coup les
mauvaises nouvelles sont des bonnes
nouvelles pour toi et pour tes quelques
amis et euh et et tu et c'est un endroit
où tout est permis. euh
parce que c'est toi qui fait les règles.
Donc euh donc c'est un endroit assez
chouette et donc j'ai voulu le faire sur
scène et me me faire un un trip où je
vole comme ça
qui passe. On est tous dans on est tous
dans ce royaume.
On est dans la vraie vie dans un royaume
d'enculé.
Non
non les gens les gens sont pas des
[__]
Ceux qui nous dirigent.
Bah après
pour parler de ceux qui nous dirigent,
je trouve que le terme est pas assez
fort
parce que Mais non mais c'est trop
populaire. C'est c'est c'est des mots
qui nous appartiennent à nous. Ça c'est
des gens normaux. On se traite d'enculer
entre nous. Ça serait ça serait ça
serait salir ce mot que de le que de le
destiner à un homme politique.
Tu as un autre terme
euh
c'est des avatars.
C'est des avatars
et ils ne savent pas eux-mêmes de quoi.
D'accord. Euh
euh
toujours pas de de partenariat avec Hugo
Boss ?
Non, mais j'aimerais bien parce que je
les achète du coup les fringues.
Euh, est-ce que Pierre des proches a
raison ou est-ce qu'il a tort quand on
peut dire quand on peut rire de tout ?
Voilà, exactement une phrase qui a été
totalement sortie de son contexte.
Euh tu as des proches, je je sais plus,
je je vais peut-être dire une connerie,
on verra bien. Mais
je je je crois je crois qu'il a dit
cette phrase pendant le tribunal du
Flagrand délire et je je me demande pas
si c'était pas Jean-Marie Le Pen
l'invité ou je sais pas quoi. Il a dit
on peut dire de tout oui mais pas avec
n'importe qui. Donc ça ça correspondait
en tout cas à un à un contexte bien
précis et c'était pas une question qui
posait euh si si je me trompe pas. Je
crois que c'est une
je crois que c'est une question qui
n'existe pas. Je pense que c'est pour ça
que tout le monde la pose depuis 50 ans,
40 ans, 30 ans, je ne sais pas. Non,
peut-être pas 50 ans, mais en tout cas
depuis un bon moment. Euh parce qu'il y
a pas de réponse, parce que l'humour
c'est totalement subjectif. Je tu as
toujours un mec, il suffit qu'il y a un
mec qui dise non et puis alors non.
Enfin, tu vois, parce que c'est ça qui
est génial avec euh avec l'unanimité,
c'est que quand tu sors une question
comme ça euh peuton rire de tout comme
il y a pas de contexte, pas de pas de
précision, pas de machin euh Ouais. oui
ou non. Bah alors donc un mec dit non et
c'est non. Donc donc je crois que c'est
une question qui ne c'est une question
qui n'existe pas. Je crois moi je pense
que on rit de tout ou rien. Maintenant
on ne peut on n'est pas obligé de forcer
les gens à rire de tout. Après le rire
c'est pas une agression. Ce que je veux
dire c'est que on n'impose pas on n
jamais chopé un mec en disant toi tu
aimes pas les vanes sur le cancer on
t'assoit on le ligote et pendant 1 heure
et3 je lui fais des vannes sur le cancer
du pancréas. On fait pas ça aux gens.
Donc ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
pas très grave si tu aimes pas la vanne
tu changes de chaîne ou tu t'en vas ou
tu vois on il y a rien d'imposé aux gens
ça reste de l'humour. Donc c'est quelque
chose qui qui doit rester
consommé par les gens qui veulent ça à
ce moment-là. Tu vois euh tuas tu as
jamais choqué quand tu dis dans ton
spectacle un génocide c'est un bien pour
un mal.
Ah non mais là c'est sorti du contexte.
C'est à un moment donné dans le
spectacle je raconte je parle de la
police séquestre et je dis je vais vous
expliquer comment je me suis comment
j'ai connu la police séquestre. Euh mais
c'est c'est une histoire vraie. Euh
et je leur dis euh je me j'ai découvert
que la police séquestre existait euh
parce que euh je sortais d'une boîte ou
d'un bar, j'étais bourré machin et euh
et je rentrais chez moi. Et je dis je
faisais rien de mal hein, à part euh ah
comme tout le monde, on est un peu
bourré, on parle fort puis bon moi des
fois je moi je des fois je teste des
vannes de mon spectacle et donc je sors
cette phrase et je dis donc j'imagine
que je suis dans la rue et je gueule je
gueule le génocide un mal pour un bien
en disant en comprenant pas pourquoi les
mecs m'arrêtent. Sauf que dans la
situation, voilà, c'est beaucoup plus
drôle sur scène et donc et donc et donc
cette phrase est un exemple de phrase et
justement je prend exactement cette
phrase là parce que parce que sorti du
contexte euh et en imaginant la scène,
ça c'est marrant.
L'armée, tu en parles un peu,
l'opération sentinelle, trois glands
autour d'un McDonald's son chargeur. Je
spécifie pas que c'est l'opération
sentinelle.
Ouais. Bah c'est c'est
parce qu'elle arrivé plus tard.
Non parce que quand j'en quand moi j'ai
écrit ça, ça existait pas encore. Donc
je parlais pas ça. Je parlais simplement
du fait que pirat carlat
euh ouais je sais pas comment ça
s'appelait mais en tout cas c'était
juste parce que c'est c'est vrai que
dans les gares il y a souvent beaucoup
de beaucoup de militaires et que et que
pour avoir pas mal de potes militaires,
il disait on a rien à [__] là parce
que parce qu'on a pas les armes
adaptées, parce que de toute façon on
peut pas tirer, parce que parce que on
n'est pas on n'est pas on est on est on
est des on est formé pour d'autres
choses. simplement ça et que ils sont là
pour pour rassurer les gens. Sauf que
eux, ils ont pas envie d'être là pour
rassurer alors que au final ils sont ce
sont pas forcément les les personnes
en terme de matériel et de formation,
ils ont ils sont très efficaces sur
certaines choses et puis moins sur
d'autres et que c'est pas leur boulot
d'être là et
et voilà.
C'est pas leur boulot de rassurer.
Non. Est-ce que Est-ce que tu
leur boulot c'est leur boulot c'est de
déjà déjà parce que ça ne rassure pas.
Ça c'est le ça c'est ça ça fait partie
des des stratégies. Tu vois tu sais
quand quand
un un un
quand tu as peur c'est pour ça que les
politiques adorent faire peur aux gens
parce que quand tu as peur tu sais quand
on tuentends un bruit très très fort ton
premier réflex c'est de regarder partout
autour de toi parce que tu veux savoir
d'où vient le danger et tu sécurises
l'espace. Tu vois, tu ça vient pas de
là, ça vient pas de là, ça vient pas là,
ça vient pas de là. Tu vois, tu
sécurises, tu veux que les choses
c'est c'est humain. Tu vois, tu as un
truc qui t'agresse alors tu veux savoir
ce qui déjà n'est pas agressif et n'est
pas dangereux pour toi. Alors, si tu
veux garder quelqu'un dans la peur, dans
le but
qu'il te laisse au pouvoir, tu lui dis
que c'est très compliqué. Voilà, c'est
très compliqué parce que comme c'est
très compliqué, il y a que il y a que
toi qui peut le faire parce que c'est
très compliqué. Puis comme ça arrange
tout le monde parce que personne n'a
envie de faire des trucs compliqués. On
te dire OK donc c'est très compliqué
puis on va pas le changer alors on va
pas changer de gouvernement parce que
comme c'est très compliqué mais qui sont
dessus on va mettre un nouveau même s'il
est bien mais il va rien comprendre
comme c'est très compliqué on va te dire
que on est en guerre donc là bon toi tu
es dégoûté tuapends que tu es en guerre
tuétais pas au courant du truc on te dit
tu es en guerre ah bon d'accord donc
c'est chaud c'est chaud pour te rappeler
que tu es en guerre on te met des
militaires dans tes gares tu es en
guerre c'est la guerre ok
euh
qui peuvent rien faire pour toi et qui
eux-même n'ont pas envie d'être là.
Enfin, c'est tout.
Et on te dit euh
que la situation
peut s'arranger
mais que c'est très complexe
et qu'on a jamais connu ça.
Ce qui est faux, bien sûr.
J'invite tout le monde à aller voir la
liste des attentats en France. Euh il y
a eu des attentats. Alors je crois que
c'est l'un des plus meurtriers voir
peut-être le plus meurtrier celui du
Bataclan et c'est dramatique. Mais
pourquoi en fait c'est déjà suffisamment
dramatique ? Il y a pas besoin d'en
rajouter à part si tu as des intérêts
personnels. Si tu veux rassurer les gens
tu peux les rassurer là. Il te rassure
pas. Il te laisse il te laisse en
suspend comme ça. Il te laisse en
suspend parce que comme tu es en
suspend, tu es fébrile et comme tu es
fébrile, tu as pas envie de bouger des
choses, tu veux les sécuriser. Donc
c'est comme ça que tu gardes aussi en en
partie le pouvoir. Et c'est ça qui qui a
pu m'énerver par exemple sur le plateau
dont on n pas couché avec Vals, c'est
parce que c'est parce que je je sens
cette je sens cette cette manipulation
et que et que je la trouve malhonnête et
je trouve que c'est je trouve que c'est
très très malhonnête. copain Manuel
Valson.
Mais j'ai pas eu assez le le on devait
partir un peu au Maroc ensemble, il a
annulé donc mais c'est je je le je je le
connais pas mais le peu peu je peu que
je connaisse, j'ai pas j'ai pas envie de
l'inviter à nouvel an. Mais après on
peut on peut se tromper hein, mais a
priori on a pas beaucoup d'affinité.
Voilà, il est en Espagne là. Euh est-ce
qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut parler euh
des gilets jaunes ?
Ah bah oui, on peut
les gilets jaunes. C'est c'est pour toi
c'est quoi ? Euh
bah pour moi c'est euh
j'étais à l'étranger quand ça a démarré
donc j'ai pris un peu le truc en cours
de route mais
pour moi c'est c'est le c'est la
représentation
du ralbol général
des gens je c'est enfin qu'est-ce qui
croit que ils vont pouvoir continuer à
faire ça aux gens en permanence de
continuer à à leur raconter que des
conneries en permanence pendant qu'ils
vont remettre des dégions d'honneur à
l'Arabie Saoudite pendant qu'il
t'augmentent ça, qu' t'augmentent ça,
qui t'augmente ça. On leur dit, on dit
aux gens oui, vous allez pouvoir gagner
plus. Sauf que il te module des lois qui
font qu'on t'augmente de 200 € d'un coup
coûte à 600 € d'un point en plus. Alors
tu dis ne m'augmentez pas. Il y a quand
même des gens tu peux pas les augmenter
parce queils te disent je vais perdre de
l'argent je quand même et je te le dis
parce que moi je suis pas trop
maintenant. Et j'ai et j'ai voulu il y a
pas très longtemps augmenter un employé.
Il m'a dit "J'ai fait mes calculs, si tu
m'augmentes de temps, je peux combien
hein ça je perds de l'argent."
Alors donc si ta seule lueur d'espoir
c'est une augmentation et que quand on
t'augmente tu perds de l'argent, bah à
un moment donné les mecs c'est normal,
je un moment donné les gens ils disent
il se passe un truc et c'est la goutte
d'eau. Il y a un truc ça. Bon ça suffit.
Hop, gilet en tout cas parce que parce
que c'est vachement dur. Je veux dire,
moi j'ai été j'ai de la chance
maintenant, je gagne très bien ma vie.
Donc je vais pas me
On sait toujours pas combien
hein.
On sait toujours pas combien.
Mais parce que je te jure, je ne sais
pas en vrai. En vrai,
mais je je peux pas te dire parce que je
sais pas ce que tu peux 15000.
Mais en fait, ça dépend ce que tu
appelles gagner. Est-ce que tu parles de
mon salaire à moi, de ce que moi
j'encaisse sur mes sur à moi en perso ou
ma boîte, tu vois. Moi en perso, je ne
sais pas. Je crois que [__] en fait je
te jure, je sais même pas te dire parce
qu'en plus je fais au moins. Moi parce
que ce que je fais c'est que moi, c'est
des crédits, c'est même pas moi qui le
fait. En gros, j'ai un j'ai un train de
vie qu'on adapte en fonction. Donc je ne
sais même pas, tu vois, il y a peut-être
des mois c'est 3000, peut-être des mois
c'est 7. Des fois, moi j'adapte comme ça
le le truc, tu vois. Et même l'argent
que je vais mettre de côté, c'est pour
un projet qui est déjà prévu et on met
en fonction. Donc très sincèrement,
c'est difficile à dire. Mais en tout
cas, ce que je peux te dire, c'est que
je vis très bien et que je peux voyager.
Je suis pas obligé de Je peux dire ce
qui a changé dans ma vie, c'est que ce
qui a changé dans ma vie, c'est que je
ne regarde pas le prix en faisant les
courses. Ça c'est incroyable comme truc,
de pouvoir ne pas regarder les prix
quand tu fais les courses. Ça c'est
vraiment génial. Que si je veux faire un
resto, je fais un resto. Si je veux
faire un voyage, je fais un voyage. Que
en gros tout ce qui avant nécessitait de
mettre de côté, de faire attention au
prix et cetera, je n'ai plus besoin de
de je n'ai plus besoin de de compter. Je
dois je dois quand même, je me comprends
mais c'est plus un problème et ça c'est
une liberté incroyable. Voilà. Le reste
très sincèrement c'est dans les société.
Maintenant pour revenir au gilets jaunes
effectivement moi je je je comprends
sincèrement
le ralbol général des gens. Moi,
tu sais, on dit "Ah oui, l'essence."
J'entends des gens parler de ce truc
d'essence comme un truc un peu oui ah
oui, ils sont énervés à cause de
l'essence. Mais c'est pas c'est pas rien
par exemple l'essence, tu vois. Par
exemple, mon père, il cherchait un
boulot il y a encore pas très très
longtemps de cela et
et il habite parce que mes parents
étaient dans les Ardenes puis ils ont
perdu leur magasins. Ça ce que
j'expliquais dans ils étaient commerçant
de proximité. Ils ont des carottes d'un
petit commerce dans un quartier
populaire à Charleville Mir et puis
alors ils ont perdu le magasin, ils sont
allés dans le sud parce que on a de la
famille là-bas et cetera. Et dans le sud
de la France, par exemple, c'est pas
simple parce que tu as des villages où
il y a pas énormément de de boulot et
euh tu as très vite énormément de route
à faire pour aller travailler. Et je me
souviens de mon père qui cherchait un
job en tant qu'agent de sécurité. Et il
y a il y a par exemple il y a il y avait
un magasin qui était OK pour le prendre,
mais ce que ça lui coûtait en essence,
c'était pas rentable. En fait, ce qui
gagnait moins les charges, moins
l'essence, moins les impôts et cetera,
c'était pas rentable. Donc c'est pas
rien l'essence. C'est pas juste on en a
marre de payer. Non, c'est c'est
important l'essence. C'est très
important. La plupart des gens
l'essence, ils en ont besoin juste pour
aller travailler. Donc je comprends qu'à
un moment donné pour
aller survivre en fait.
Oui. pour aller survivre. Alors à un
moment donné quand on te quand on te dit
"Mais qu'est-ce que mais [__] !" Tu
vas à ta pompe et tu fais ça et tu dis
quoi combien ? Mais évidemment que les
gens ils pètent un câble déjà tu vas
bosser à faire passer
le Non, j'ai pas de message à faire
passer parce que je suis pas leur
porte-parole. Moi ce que je peux dire
c'est que je comprends cette colère. Euh
alors après, tu as toujours évidemment
euh c'est forcé, je dire le après tu as
des tu as des gens ça ça ça part en
cacahuète, tu as toujours des gens qui
vont trop loin, toujours des gens qui
partent en couille et c'est dommage
parce que évidemment ça ça desserre le
mouvement et puis voilà. Mais
je dire c'est que dans tout dans tout
mouvement qui engrange
un grand rassemblement, tu as toujours
quelques quelques débiles qui vont
casser un peu la fête. Mais bon, c'est
comme un nouvel an avec tes copains. Tu
en a toujours un qui finit par vomir sur
le chien ou rentrer dans la chambre de
ta mère pour faire des trucs bizarres.
Donc ça empêche pas que tu as quand même
passé un bon nouvel an. Donc non, le
message le message il est simple, c'est
que je comprends je comprends cette je
comprends vraiment vraiment cette
révolte.
Pourquoi tu dis que Sarkozi il a pris
des décisions qui ont fait du mal à la
France ?
Bah parce que bah parce que c'est le cas
parce que je je je pense que
je pense qu'il y a
je crois que c'est quelqu'un qui a qui a
mis j'ai pas en tête vraiment tous les
trucs hein parce que ça fait un moment
maintenant mais
la Libye un peu non ? la Libye par
exemple. Ouais, je pense que je pense
que que la plupart du temps quand on on
a pu intervenir dans des pays euh
pour apporter la démocratie pour les
celui-ci pour apporter la démocratie
comme on y va pas pour on y va jamais
pour ces raisons-là, je pense que
va pourquoi ?
Ah bon ? On y va toujours pour C'est
pour ça que j'ai écrit de pièces à
route, c'était pour Ouais. où ou le
livre effectivement
euh euh c'est le livre à Pier à Mossou.
C'était c'était un hommage au film de
BHL ?
Non
non non, c'était beaucoup plus Non,
c'était pas un hommage. Non, c'était
c'était vraiment pour tu vois, c'est
pour montrer que des gens qui peuvent
même parfois être ennemis finalement se
rassemblent à partir du moment où il
faut euh gagner de l'argent et
convaincre le peuple, convaincre les
gens de nous suivre. Moi quand
j'écrivent de pièces à bureau, je suis
parti de ce principe, je me suis dit je
prends en fait je prends toujours un un
truc instinctif justement un truc des
mago tu sais ces trucs un peu on dit oh
vous êtes des mago oh c'est un cliché
tout ça je prends toujours une idée
comme ça un peu cliché un peu des mago
et ah tiens on va voir si elle est vraie
et là sur la guerre j'ai dit tiens je
vais partir du principe je vais me dire
toutes les guerres modernes sont quoi
qu'il arrive toujours toujours
là
pour servir les intérêts économiques
d'un pays
ou d'un mec, on va me dire "Ah bah oui,
mais ça évidemment." Ben non, pas
évidemment. Pourquoi évidemment ? Il y a
plein de peuples qui ont soutenu plein
de guerre qui était là pour sois
d'autres raisons puis on s'en est aperçu
après que c'était pas forcément pour ces
raisons là. Donc je pense que c'est
je pense que des choses comme ça par
exemple, c'est des choses qu'on pas
facilement. Je pense que ça a des
conséquences qu'on qu'on imagine pas. Je
je
il n'y a aucune bonne raison de faire la
guerre.
BHL BHL, c'est ton copain ?
Bah je le connais pas.
Euh
il a pris il a fait des des choses qu'on
qu'on fait mal à la France lui ou pas ?
Bah oui, il a soutenu il a soutenu des
il a soutenu il a soutenu des mouvements
armés et cetera et cetera. Donc donc moi
à partir du moment où tu à partir du
moment où tu te sens en mesure en fait,
qui qui es-tu pour
te lever un matin ?
Étudier un conflit, une zone, je ne sais
pas et dire avec certitude
envoyer des avions.
Comment tu dors ? Comment tu dors [__]
le soir ? Comment tu fais ? Tu sais ce
moment où tu éteins la lampe de chevet ?
Tu sais c'est quelques secondes je parle
toujours de ça que moi mes angoisses
arrivent toujours ce momentl tu sais tu
te couches ah ça bonne journée ou bon ça
c'est s'il y a quelqu'un des fois tu
fais ça il y a personne plus à côté de
toi et alors là tu éteint ta lampe de
chevet et il y a ces quelques secondes
tu sais terrible qui arrivent avant que
tu t'endormes si tu t'endors ce moment
où tu es tout seul avec toi-même tout
seul avec ta voix tu sais où tu sais il
fait noir et tu es dans un lit alors tu
peux être n'importe où tu peux n'importe
quel âge tu peux et ce moment-là quo
quand la journée tu as dit on va envoyer
des avions
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quoi ?
S'il se passe rien,
c'est que tu es dangereux.
Si comment tu peux être sûr et certain
que c'est la bonne décision à prendre ?
Comment tu peux être à 100 % convaincu
que tuer des gens, c'est la seule
solution ? Je ne comprends pas. C'est
Est-ce que tu peux nous faire la blague
avec la prison de bouche d'Aesh et les
cadres de Saddam Hussein ? C'est pas une
blague. C'est pas une blague. Je raconte
que parce que moi ça m'avait vachement
surpris parce que
moi je trouve que c'est par exemple,
j'explique pourquoi je dis ça parce que
en fait je raconte aux gens enfin
j'explique aux gens mais c'est pas une
vanne, c'est pas un moment où je suis
une vanne mais je raconte aux gens que
les que les principaux dirigeants au
départ de de de Daesh sont des généraux
de Saddam Hussein et des anciens
d'Al-Qaïda. Et c'est important de dire
les généraux de SAM Hussein parce que
euh parce que à ce moment-là ces mecs-là
n'ont jamais revendiqué un islam, n'ont
jamais prôné des islam et cetera. Et ça
c'est important parce que euh par
exemple, je trouve ça très ennuyeux
quand euh
quand on parle de terroriste et d'islam.
Alors, je sais que eux se revendiquent
de l'islam et cetera et ce mais tu sais
quand on dit l'islamisme et tout, il y a
il y a il y a il y a un propos qui
suggère un peu que potentiellement
dans le prisme de l'islam, il dans les
extrêmes, tu peux avoir des mecs qui
vont avec une kalashikov. Non, c'est
c'est une secte, tu vois. C'est des
sectes. C'est pas un mouvement
extrémiste de l'islam. C'est des sectes.
Quand tu as des mecs qui revendiquent
être les apôtres de Jésus et qui vont
flinguer des gens, on dit pas les
extrémistes catholique,
extrémistes chrétiens, non, on dit la
secte du Tu vois. Alors, il faut faire
une chose pour tout le monde parce que
je trouve que je trouve que ça met un
truc hyper malsin dans la tête des gens.
Moi, j'ai mon premier spectacle
s'appelle Alléluia bordel. J'ai amené le
Coran, la Bible et la Torah sur scène et
je me suis pas fait avec des copains. Je
suis totalement hâté et je le revendique
et dans Alléluia bordel, j'ai bien pris
j'ai bien fait attention à taper avec la
même violence sur toutes les religions.
Donc donc je je je sais ce que c'est que
l'extrémisme religieux, mais je veux
dire c'est on n'est pas il faut il faut
faire attention avec les mots et les
gens qui prononcent ces mots en
l'occurrence les politiques savent la
définition des mots parce qu'ils ont des
des
gens le savent he mais il faut le
rappeler de temps en temps qu'ils ont
des cours. Faut bien comprendre que
chaque mot d'un homme politique est
choisi pesé. Ils savent exactement quand
ils emploient un mot quel est l'impact
sur ton inconscient, ton conscient, sur
la masse, sur ils savent très bien. Et
je trouve par exemple que il est
important de rappeler que à la tête de
Daesh au départ, il y a des gens euh qui
sont presque même pas musulmans alors
qu'on ne vienne pas nous parler euh d'un
euh
je sais plus quel motrouvés dans les
mêmes prisons de Bush où ils ont
Oui. Oui. Voilà. Parce qu'en fait parce
qu'effectivement quand Bush a mis dans
la même prison les mecs d'Al-Qaïda qui
l'avait attrapé puis les anciens
généraux de Salam Hussein alors tu mets
les deux tu mets les deux dans la même
prison ils ont rien à [__] les prisons
là-bas sont pas ouf donc du coup bah ils
discutent et puis ben ils s'entendent
bien on plein de point commun donc du
coup bah forcément en sortant il disent
ça serait quand même chouette ne nous
perdons pas de j donc tu vois puis sur
Linkini il se retrouve et puis ils
disent ben montons une start-up ensemble
et puis et puis ça devient et puis ça
devient da et c'est quand même
intéressant de avoir ça. Alors, ça veut
pas dire que c'est Bouche qui a qu' a
fabriqué Daesh, mais ça veut dire que
parfois en voulant soi-disant la paix et
en faisant la guerre, finalement ce que
tu obtiens, c'est encore plus de guerre.
Euh, on va passer aussi. Tu veux pas
nous faire un petit peu le la création
de l'État Israala-palestinien là ? Mais
j'ai pas des vannes. On dirait que On
dirait que j'ai des que sur scène j'ai
des j'ai des blagues comme ça. Euh euh
j'ai des blag comme ça sur le parce que
le la partie du euh de cette partie du
spectacle où j'évoque euh entre autres
la création d'Israël, c'est une partie
qui dure 25 minutes. En plus, je crois
que je parle à 300 km/h dans cette
partie. Donc ça va être difficile de te
la résumer.
On va passer aux questions d'internet.
Euh
tu fais des blagues sur la première la
deuxième guerre mondiale dans ton livre.
Est-ce que c'est l'éducation par
l'humour ?
Moi, je m'éduque moi-même en en en
faisant des trucs parce que il faut bien
comprendre que c'est pas du tout des
connaissances que moi j'avais au départ.
J'ai pas un jour j'ai pas ouvert comme
ça dire alors la première scolarité en
seconde,
j'ai arrêté au bout de 2 mois de
secondes et les de mois c'était pas ouf.
Donc euh je euh c'était euh je j'ai
vraiment pas retenu grand-chose du truc.
Mais
moi en fait je prends les trucs comme je
suis pas un intellectuel, je les étudie
et il y a plein de trucs qui me font
marrer. Donc alors après ça éduque
forcément les gens mais parce que moi je
m'éduque avec eux tu vois mais c'est pas
j'ai pas une volonté d'éduquer les gens
tu vois. J'ai d'abord une volonté de
m'éduquer moi. Paren en plus c'est vrai.
Autre question internet. Est-il prêt à
manifester avec les gilets jaunes ? Je
vais pas aux manifestations
parce que même si je comprends leur
colère et cetera et cetera, moi si je
veux avoir de l'impact,
je dois rester,
comment dire, je dois rester
impliqué de manière neutre. C'est-à-dire
que je dois pouvoir si je mets si je
mets un gilet jaune et que je vais avec
eux, il faut que j'aille à toutes les
manifes en fait parce que ça serait
parce queà partir du moment où tu
participes pas à un truc en fait
c'est le même problème tu sais pour les
par exemple pour les quand je donne un
exemple quand j'ai commencé à faire des
sketchs à la télé au début j'ai fait
plein de trucs sur le racisme. Alors
tout le monde ah vous êtes le racisme
vous révolte. J'ai dans ma tête, je dis
faut que j'arrête de faire sketch sur le
racisme parce que il croit que c'est une
espèce de de tu vois de de bataille que
j'ai mais c'est une des bataille après
alors du coup après j'ai arrêté et j'ai
fait sketch avec l' handicapé alors là
c'était donc je suis le représentant des
handicapés tu mais pas du tout et moi je
change de thème tout le temps parce que
j'arrive pas en fait à mettre du
quantitatif ou du qualitatif sur le
malheur c'est impossible et comme
maintenant quand je quand je fais
quelque chose il y a une répercussion
médiatique et cetera, je trouve qu'il
est de ma responsabilité d'essayer au
maximum de de ne pas faire d'une manière
ou d'une autre préférence à une cause
plutôt qu'une autre parce qu'en plus
tu te retrouves à un moment donné dans
quelque chose avec des gens autour de
toi, il y en a il y en a 50 puis un jour
on va aller dans une émission de télé
puis on va me mettre une photo de moi
avec 50 mecs, on va me faire un petit
rond rouge sur la tête d'un mec derrière
que j'ai jamais vu. Puis on va me dire
"Ce mec là a tué des enfants de là ?" Je
dis "Ah bon ?" Donc vous le soutenez ?
Ah bah non. Et puis tu te retrouves, tu
vois. Donc je crois que il faut il faut
être vigilant euh sur les trucs qu'on
fait. Je crois que euh
je crois que c'est pas mon rôle de faire
ça.
La censure existe-t-il ? Comment
est-elle exercée à la télé ? A-t-il été
confronté à l'autocensure ?
Alors, est-ce que la censure existe ?
Écoutez, apparemment tout le monde le
dit
qu'elle doit exister. Euh
en fait, moi ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est je on peut je ne peux pas
entendre que il y a 30 ans, alors cette
fameuse phrase il y a 30 ans, on pouvait
dire des choses qu'on peut plus dire.
Quel artiste arrive devant son public à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui et dit aux gens à
son public mesdames et messieurs, voilà
je suis un artiste qui est censuré. Il y
a 30 ans, on pouvait dire des trucs
qu'on ne peut plus dire. Alors voilà, je
vais vous faire mon sketch. Mais b fais
pas ton sketch. Alors tu es en train de
nous dire que il y a 30 ans, toi-même
toi tu es humoriste, tu dis il y a 30
ans, faut dire des trucs qu'on peut plus
dire maintenant. [__] mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette ce baissage de bras
d'abandon ? C'est ça la promesse qu'on
fait aux gens, c'est qu'il y a 30 ans,
on pouvait dire des trucs plus
maintenant. C'est pas vrai. C'est pas
vrai. Seulement, il faut les nuls. Tu tu
revois les sketch passer maintenant ?
Bien sûr.
Genre Royal Rabin, ça passe.
Je me souviens plus de Royal Rabin très
sincèrement mais mais je vois pas
pourquoi un truc passerait pas. Ce que
je dire c'est qu'après tout correspond à
une époque aussi. Il y a peut-être des
choses qui passeraient plus maintenant
parce que ça correspond à les blagues de
Michel Leb avec les Shinok. Bah Michel
Leb, Michel Leb, c'est encore un autre
problème. Moi Michel me fait pas
beaucoup rire, sauf quand c'est pas son
texte. Euh donc c'est
peut-être peut-être des fois en fait des
fois peut-être le plagia est positif
parce que ça lui a permis quand même
d'avoir quelques bonnes vannes. Mais je
pense que de manière générale, tu ne
peux pas dire ça aux gens. Le je je
crois que si tu es assis quelque part et
que tu dis je suis censuré mais que tu
es assis là, qu'est-ce que tu fous là ?
C'est que tu as signé un contrat. et que
tu respectes les clauses, pas que tu as
été censuré. Censuré, c'est quand sans
ton accord, sans ton accord, on coupe
des vannes dans un sketch à toi ou que
on te on te on te boycotte de quelque
part parce qu'on sait ce que tu vas
dire. Ça c'est de la censure. Mais
j'entends trop d'humoristes nous parler
de cette liberté d'expression. Moi, je
crois que ça arrange bien tout le monde
parce que on dit on ne peut plus rien
dire. Comme ça, quand tu fais une
mauvaise vanne à la télé et que tu te
fais insulter sur internet, tu dis "Ah
ben voyez, on ne peut plus rien dire."
Et puis surtout quand tu dis rien et que
tu ne t'engages pas et que tu ne te
prends pas de risque pour t'impliquer
dans les choses, tu dis je ne je ne
m'implique pas puisque il y a 30 ans, on
pouvait tout dire mais maintenant on
peut plus rien dire. Euh moi je crois
que c'est pas vrai. La preuve mon
spectacle vend de pièout, il est passé
euh samedi dernier en clair sur ces h
avec des propos soi-disant qu'on ne peut
pas tenir et des sujets soi-disant qu'on
ne peut pas évoquer. Pourtant il y a pas
eu de coup et cetera. Je sais pas quand
on parle par exemple du conflit
israopestinien, j'en parle j'en parle
spectacle la colonisation plein plein de
choses et je l'évoque dans le spectacle
sans aucun problème. Alléluia bordel
j'amène le Coran, la Bible et la Torah
sur scène. On se dit "Ah mais non mais
vous êtes vous êtes fous mais les
musulmans vont vous tuer.
Mais enfin mais vous mais mais de mais
de quoi vous parlez ? Enfin mais les
juifs vont vous tuer. Les chrétiens vont
vous tuer. Vous avez la Bible, le Coran,
la Torah ! Mais personne m'a tué ! Ils
étaient dans la salle, on s'est marré.
Enfin, je veux dire pourquoi ? parce que
la les premières victimes des de tout
type d'extrémismes religieux sont
souvent les communautés religieuses
elles-mêmes. Je les premières victimes
de de de Daesh, c'est c'est les
musulmans. Donc à un moment donné en
fait juste euh on ne peut pas dire aux
gens qu'il n'y a pas de liberté
d'expression. Moi personnellement, je je
dis à peu près ce que je veux et quand
enfin non, je dis ce que je veux et
quand on ne veut pas que je dise ce que
je veux, je ne dis rien. Je n'y vais
pas. Donc et puis en fait qu'on me donne
des exemples. Alors parce que il y a
trop de mecs qui disent "Ah, on peut
plus rien dire, on peut plus rien dire."
Moi, à chaque fois que j'ai eu un mec
sur un plateau et je lui ai dit
"Donne-nous un exemple, j'ai pas
d'exemple."
Là, j'ai 25 questions qui traitent de
dieu donné. Est-ce que c'est un
humoriste de génie ou un antisémite ?
raciste.
Dieu donné, c'est ce qu'on appelle
liberté.
Dieu donné, c'est ce qu'il appelle un un
cas d'école. C'est que le problème de
Dieu donné, c'est que si vous n'en
parlez pas, on dit "Ah ben vous avez pas
d'en parler." Si vous en parlez, jour
des mecs, ils vont vous dire "Ah, il a
tort ou alors si vous en parlez d'un
coup de fin". Je c'est ce qu'on appelle
un cas d'école parce que moi j'en ai
déjà beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup parlé de
Dieu donné.
Quand il y a eu le truc au départ, j'ai
rien dit parce que ah c'était la course
aux humoristes qui avaient donné leur
avis à la télévision sur Dieu donné
juste pour pouvoir placer la promo de
leur spectacle. Donc hors de question
que je participe à ça. Moi j'en ai parlé
bien plus t part quand ça commença un
peu à retomber. J'ai donné mon avis sur
sur Dieu donné euh avis qui n'a pas plu
au principal intéressé. Mais de toute
façon, moi euh pour résumer
la vie qui était en résumé, c'était quoi
?
Bah la vie en résumé, c'est que à partir
du moment où euh
à partir du moment où tu où ce que tu
joues sur scène euh correspond aux idées
que tu as dans la vie,
tu n'es plus dans une dénonciation.
Alors si tu n'es plus dans une
dénonciation,
bah alors c'est plus une caricature,
c'est plus un personnage, c'est toi. Et
si toi tu es ça, moi j'ai pas envie de
te voir.
Voilà, en gros
question internet. Comment
s'informe-t-il ?
Alors, j'essaie d'avoir plein de de
trucs différents pour m'informer. Donc,
j'essaie d'avoir après ça dépend des
sujets, mais des sources. Donc, j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup de sources, tout est
très sourcé. Euh, pratiquement chaque
propos que je peux tenir normalement est
sourcé. On essaie d'avoir plusieurs
sources si on en trouve plusieurs. Euh
mais il y en a au moins une à chaque
fois que que je parle. Euh je demande
l'is principaux concernés. Ça c'est très
important
parce que tu apprends quand tu voyages
aussi que ce qu'on te raconte de ce pays
dans le tien, c'est quand même rarement
la réalité de ce qui se passe. Et
les livres, les livres parce que
internet aussi. En gros, je croise les
sources, tu vois. Je vais prendre
l'internet, je vais prendre des avis, je
vais prendre du livre, je vais prendre
et de la presse. Enfin, j'essaie de
mélanger un peu tous les prismes et tous
les supports possibles et à un moment
donné, on arrive à un truc qui est ça
doit être à peu près la vérité doit être
à peu près par là.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
On n pas vu l'heure passer. C'est c'est
très agréable de discuter. Trois trois
dernières questions. Comment tu fais
pour
Ça peut nous emmener sur 2 heures.
Comment tu fais pour gérer les insultes
sur internet ?
Écoute, j'en ai j'en ai plus beaucoup.
Est-ce que tu les regardes plus ?
Si, je les regarde mais des insultes,
c'est pas enfin tu vois un mec qui va te
dire "Eh, Ferrari, il va te faire
enculer." Tu sais pas, tu imagines si je
m'effondrais à chaque fois ?
Merde, il va faire [__] Je crois
qu'il a pas aimé mon sketch.
Non, franchement, ça me fait pas
grand-chose. C'est c'est dur, c'est des
fois de recevoir un truc genre "J'ai
préféré ton premier spectacle." Ça ça tu
envie de l'appeler de dire "C'est vrai
?" ou "Oh, tu mais non." Puis après, tu
sais quand tu as la chance d'avoir
tellement de monde dans les salles et
tout, c'est tellement c'est tellement et
puis je suis un humoriste provocateur.
Je je peux pas me plaindre d'avoir des
gens qui m'aiment pas, sinon j'existe
pas. Je c'est c'est je si je provoque
personne, si j'emmerde personne, je suis
plus je suis plus un emmerdeur.
Les projets avec l'Afrique,
les projets avec l'Afrique, avec
l'Afrique,
les projets avec l'Afrique euh bah ils
sont en cours, c'est pas des projets.
Donc moi, je suis là-bas deux trois fois
par an où je vais enregistrer les
émissions de télévision et où je
développe vraiment ma carrière
d'humoriste là-bas. Et puis euh
quelle chaîne euh
euh on fait pour Canal Plus Afrique puis
d'autres d'autres chaînes africaines et
euh euh et et moi mais moi là-bas, je
suis vraiment que comédien, auteur euh
et cetera et euh parce que j'étais
personne, ils m'ont vraiment invité,
maintenant ça marche bien et tout donc
j'ai une vraie carrière qui s'ouvre
là-bas et ça m'éclate complètement. Et
par contre, je me suis aperçu que les
africains, les grands humoristes
africains nevenaient jamais jouer en
France pour la diaspora. Donc on a monté
un plateau là, je vais pouvoir te donner
une exclu qu'on a pas
on a monté un plateau une fois qui
s'appelle sans visa. Tous les plus
grands humoristes africains qui venaient
jouer à Paris. On l'a fait deux années
de suite, ça a été un carton. Donc là,
on a décidé d'ouvrir un festival, le
premier festival d'humour africain à
Paris qui sera en avril. J'ai plus les
dates, on va ouvrir la les ventes là
dans quelques jours. Je l'annonce he
comme ça c'est fait. Il va s'appeler le
CFA Festival, le comédie festival
africain. Il n'y voit rien d'autre comme
suggestion. pas CFA,
c'est le Comédie Festival Africain,
c'est tout. Et euh donc c'est le
festival CFA et donc on va on va avoir
un plateau, un grand plateau au casino
de Paris avec toutes les toutes ces
grandes stars de l'humour africaine qui
viennent voir qui viennent en France et
on aura aussi tous ces humoristes qui
vont jouer leur solo dans des théâtres
un peu partout à Paris. Ça va durer 15
jours je crois. et on va faire même une
tournée, une petite tournée mais de des
5 6 7 h plus grosses villes en France
avec le plateau des humoristes des
humoristes africains. Et j'invite
vraiment et je fais pas mon truc des
magoin.
J'invite vraiment les personnes qui
n'ont pas forcément d'origine africaine
à venir découvrir ces mecs parce que
c'est fascinant d'avoir des gens qui
parlent ta langue
et qui ont vécu
des choses similaires mais qui le voi
d'une autre manière. Il c'est une autre
manière de voir la vie avec la même
langue et et pas mal de références
communes. C'est c'est vraiment vraiment
génial.
Trois bouquins à conseiller.
Euh, trois bouquins à conseiller.
Appuie à Mosou.
Euh
les éditions,
les éditions, c'est Michel Lafond. Euh,
un trois bouquins. Faut quand même lire,
je crois le livre de mon de mon copain
Éric Antoine. Je fais un peu de
corporate parce que parce que c'est
parce que le bouquin est plein de poésie
et très chouette. Et
le titre
et euh je ne sais plus le titre. Vous
pouvez vous [__] de ma gueule. Je ne
sais plus le titre. Il va me buter. Il
en a il en a sorti qu'un et là je crois
qu'il va me buter parce que je crois que
c'est pas le premier qui sort. Mais bon
c'est le dernier qui vient de sortir.
J'ai plus le titre en tê.
Le troisème
euh plus fort la vie de Philippe Croison
et comme son nom l'indique
pas mal pour lire un truc qui est qui
peut être triste et qui est en fait
vachement vachement vachement positif.
Tu vois des trucs à rajouter ?
Non. Moi ça me
Alors il faut laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations. Une bouteille à
la mer.
Euh
quand quelqu'un vous dit que
ça n'est pas possible, demandez-lui
toujours pourquoi.
C'est hyper important parce que quand tu
demandes pourquoi, souvent tu t'aperçois
qu'il y a pas de raison. C'est juste une
peur qui est transmise et on te dit ne
fais pas ça. Pourquoi ? Parce que
et souvent
souvent on comprend qu'il faut faire ce
qu'on nous déconseille de faire.
Jérémy Ferrari, merci.
Mais merci à toi. À vous.
[Musique]